Ah Ha ha.
Four,
three,
two,
one.
Boom.
Thank you.
Thanks for doing this man.
Really appreciate it.
Hey,
welcome.
It's very good to meet you.
Nice to meet you too.
And thanks for not letting this place on
fire.
You're welcome.
Later.
How does one,
I'm just in the middle of doing all the
things you do,
create cars or rockets,
all this stuff you're doing constantly
innovating,
decided to just make a flame thrower.
Where do you have time for that?
Well,
the famous Edwin,
we didn't put a lot of time into the
flame thrower,
the,
this was an off the cuff thing and um,
so have sort of like sort of a sort of a
hobby company called the boring company
which started out as a joke and we
decided to make a real um,
and,
and dig a tunnel under la and then dig.
Then people,
other people asked us to dig tunnels and
so we said yes in a few cases and then
we have a merchandise section that only
has one piece of merchandise at a time.
And we started off with a cap and there
was only one thing on,
it was just boring company.com/cap
or hat.
That's it.
And then we sold the hats,
limited limited edition,
it just said the boring company.
And then I'm big kind of space,
both the movie and in spaceballs yogurt
goes through the merchandising section
and they have a flame thrower in the
merchandising section of spaceballs.
And like the kids love that one.
That's the line of when he pulls up the
claim for.
It's like we should do a flame thrower.
So we.
Does anybody tell,
you know,
does anybody go elan,
um,
maybe for yourself,
but selling a flame thrower,
the liabilities,
all the people you're selling this
device to what kind of unhinged people
are going to be buying a flame thrower
in the first place to really want to
connect ourselves to all these potential
arsonists yeah.
It's a terrible idea.
Terrible by one.
I said,
don't buy this flame thrower to buy it.
Don't buy it.
That's what I said a bit.
Still people bought it.
Yeah.
There's nothing I can do to stop them.
You build them.
I said,
don't buy it.
It's a bad idea.
How many did you make your w?
It's dangerous.
It's got,
it's wrong.
Don't buy it.
People bought it.
I just couldn't stop them.
How many did you make?
$20,000
and they're all gone in three,
I think four days.
It sold out in four days.
Are you going to do another run?
No,
now let's it.
Yes.
Oh,
I said,
well do 20 that we did $50,000.
40,000
hats.
I'm at.
And,
and um,
that was a million dollars and he's
like,
okay,
well we'll sell something for 10 million
and that was 20,000
flame throwers at $500 each.
They went fast.
Yeah.
How do you have the time to do that
though?
I mean,
I understand that it's not a big deal in
terms of all the other things that you
do,
but how do you have time to do anything?
I just,
I don't understand your time management
skills.
I mean,
I didn't spend much time on this flame
thrower.
I mean,
to be totally frank,
it's actually just a roofing torch with
an air rifle cover.
It's not a real flame thrower,
which is why it says not a flame
thrower.
That's why we were very clear.
This is not actually a flame thrower
and,
and it also were told that various
countries were,
were banned shipping of it would,
they would,
they would band flame throwers.
So we've got to solve this problem for
the customs agencies.
We labeled it not a flame thrower.
That work.
Is it effective?
I don't know.
I think so,
yes.
So far,
Now,
but you just said you cannot serve a
flame thrower,
but you do so many different things and
forget about the flame thrower.
Like how do you do all that other shit?
I'm like,
how do you,
how does one decide to fix la traffic by
drilling holes in the ground and who do
you even approach with that?
Like when you have this idea,
who do you talk to about that?
I mean,
I'm not saying it's going to be
successful or so,
you know,
I know it's just like asserting that
it's going to be successful,
but so far I've lived in La for 16 years
and the traffic has always been terrible
and so I don't see any other ideas for
improving the traffic.
Um,
so in desperation where you're going to
dig a tunnel and maybe that tunnel will
be successful and maybe it won't.
I'm,
I'm listening.
Yeah.
I'm not trying to convince you it's
going to work.
And are the people that you or anyone.
But you were starting this though.
This is actually a project you're
starting to implement,
right?
Yeah.
No,
we've dug about a mile.
It's quite long.
Take.
Takes a long time to Wolcott yeah.
Now when you do in this,
what,
what is the ultimate plan?
The ultimate plan is to have these in
major cities in anywhere.
There's mass congestion and just try it
out in la first.
Yeah,
it's,
it's in La because I mostly live in la.
That's the reason as a terrible place to
dig tunnels.
This is one of the worst places.
Dig Tunnels,
because the does mostly because of the
paperwork you will think.
It's like,
what about seismic is actually both
tunnels are very safe in earthquakes.
Why's that?
Earthquakes.
Earthquakes are essentially of surface
phenomenon.
It's like waves on the ocean.
So if,
if,
if there's a storm,
you want to be on the,
on in a submarine.
So being in a tunnel,
it's like being in a submarine.
Now the way the towels construct is,
it's constructed out of these
interlocking segments,
kind of like a snake.
Um,
it's sort of like a snake exoskeleton
with a double seals.
And so even when the ground moves,
the it's able to,
the tunnel actually is able to shift
along with the ground like an
underground snake and it doesn't crack
or break or,
or,
and,
and it's extremely unlikely that both
seals would be broken and it's,
it's,
it's a capable of taking five
atmospheres of pressure.
It's waterproof.
Methane proof will gas proof of any kind
and,
uh,
meets old California seismic
requirements.
So when you have this idea,
who do you bring this to?
I'm not sure what you mean by that.
Well when you,
you're,
you're implementing it,
so you're digging holes in the ground
like you have to bring it to someone
that lets you do it.
Yeah.
So,
um,
there were,
there were some engineers from space x,
um,
who were,
who thought it would be cool to do this
and the guy runs it like day to day.
Steve Davis,
he's long,
longtime space x engineer.
He's great.
Um,
so steve was like,
I like to help make this happen.
He was like,
cool.
And so we started off with digging a
hole in the ground.
It's got like a permit for a pit,
a pit,
and just dug a big pit.
Do you have to tell them what the pits
for or you just say,
hey,
we just want to dig a hole.
Nice.
Fill out this form.
That's it.
Yeah,
it was a in our parking lot.
And,
but do you have to give them some sort
of a blueprint for your ultimate idea?
And do they have to approve it?
Like how does that work
now?
We just started off with a pit big pit
and I'm like,
you don't,
there's not really,
you know,
they don't really care about the
existential nature of a pit.
You just say like,
I don't want a pit,
right?
Yeah.
And a hole in the ground.
So then we got the permit for the pit
and we dug the pit and we dug it in like
three days,
two,
three days actually to 48 hours,
something like that.
Um,
cause uh,
Eric are steady,
was coming by for the hype to,
was going to attend the hyperloop
competition,
which like a student competition we have
for a who can make the fastest pod in
the hyperloop.
And uh,
he was coming.
This was get the files are going to be
on Sunday afternoon.
And so,
uh,
Eric was coming by on Sunday afternoon.
He's like,
you know,
we should take this pit.
And then like,
sure.
Eric.
Uh,
so we was like Friday morning and then
yeah.
So it was about a little over 40 hours.
Forty hours later we dug the pit.
There's like when 24 slash seven or 24
or 48 straight hours,
something like and dug this big pit and,
and,
and we're like showed eric the pit.
It's like obviously it's just a pit,
but hey,
it's holding the ground is better than
no hole in the ground.
And what do you tell them about this
pit?
I mean just said this is the starting of
this idea.
Yes,
we're going to build tunnels under la to
help funnel traffic better and their
girls and they just go,
okay.
That we've joked around about this in
the podcast before too,
like what are the person can go to the
people that run the city and go,
hey,
we're going to dig some holes on the
ground and puts him tunnels in there.
And they go,
oh yeah,
okay.
Now I know where the hole in the ground,
but it's people dig holes in the ground
all the time.
But.
But my,
my question is like,
I know how much time you must be
spending on your Tesla factory.
spending on space x and yet you still
have time to dig holes under the ground
in La and come up with these ideas and
then implement them.
Like,
I've got a million ideas.
I'm sure you just.
No shortage.
Yeah,
I just don't know how you manage your
time.
I don't understand it.
It doesn't seem.
It doesn't even seem humanly possible.
You know,
I,
I do.
Basically.
I think people like don't totally
understand what I do with my time.
They think like I'm a business guy or
something like that.
I'm like,
my wikipedia page says,
business magnate.
What would you call yourself?
A business magnet.
Please change my wikipedia page to
magnet.
They'll change right now.
He's probably already changed.
It's locked.
So somebody has to be able to unlock it
and change it to magnus.
Um,
no.
I,
I do engineering and manufacturing and
that kind of thing.
That's like 80 percent or more of my
time
ideas.
And then the implementation of those
Yes.
That was like hardcore engineering,
like designing things,
right?
Structural,
mechanical,
electrical,
software,
a user interface,
engineering,
aerospace,
engineering.
But you must understand there's not a
whole lot of human beings like you.
You know that right?
To your an audit teams?
Yes.
To chimps.
Like me,
we're all chimps.
Yeah,
we are.
We're wanting to watch one notch above a
chimp.
Some of us are a little more confused.
When I watched you doing all these
things and I'm like,
how is this motherfucker have all this
time and all this energy and all these
ideas,
and then people just let them do these
things
because I'm an alien.
That's what I've speculated.
Yes.
I'm on record saying this in the past.
I wonder.
It's true.
I mean if there was one,
I was like,
if there was like maybe an intelligent
being that we created some ai creature
that's a superior to people,
maybe they just hang around with us for
a little while like you've been doing
and then fix a bunch of shit.
Maybe that's the way my tufts on
retainer or something like that.
You might.
Do you think you do?
Probably.
Do you wonder like you around normal
people,
you're like,
hmm.
Think what's up with these boring dumb
mother fuckers ever?
Not Bad for a human,
but I think it will not be able to hold
a candle to ai.
Hm.
You scare the shit out of me when you
talk about Ai between you and Sam
Harris.
Sure.
Consider it until at a podcast with Sam
wants.
That's great.
He made me Shit my pants.
Talking about Ai,
I realized like,
oh well this is a genie that wants out
of the bottle.
You never get it back in.
That's true.
There was a video that you tweeted about
one of those Boston dynamic robots,
like in the future it will be moving so
fast you can't see it without a strobe
light.
You could probably do that right now and
no one's really paying attention too
much.
Other than people like you or people
that are really obsessed with
technology.
All these things are happening and these
robots or did you see the one where it.
Peta put out a statement that you
shouldn't kick robots.
It's probably not wise for retribution
that their memory is pretty good.
I bet.
It's really good.
I bet it is.
Yes,
and getting better every day.
It's really.
Are you honestly,
legitimately concerned about this?
Are you the AI,
one of your main worries in regards to
the future?
Yes,
it,
it's less of a worry than it used to be
a mostly due to taking more of a
fatalistic attitude.
Hm.
So you used to have more hope and you
gave up some of it and now you don't
worry as much about ai you like this is
just what it is.
Yeah,
pretty much,
yes.
But no,
it's not necessarily bad.
It's just,
it's definitely going to be outside of
human control.
Not necessarily bad,
right?
Yeah,
it's not,
it's not necessarily bad,
it's just,
it's just outside of human control.
Now the thing that's going to be tricky
here is that it's going to be very
tempting to use ai as a weapon.
That's going to be very tempting in fact
will be used as a weapon.
Um,
so the,
the,
the onramp to serious ai,
the danger is going to be more humans
using it against each other.
I think most likely that'll be the
danger.
Yeah.
How far do you think we are from
something that can make its own mind up,
whether or not something's ethically or
morally correct or they're not at wants
to do something or whether or not he
wants to improve itself,
whether or not it wants to protect
itself from people or from other Ai.
How far away we suffer from something
that's really truly sent you in?
Well,
I mean you could argue that any group of
people like like a company is
essentially a cybernetic collective of
people and machines.
That's what a company is
and then there are different.
There's different levels of complexity
in the way these companies are formed
and then there are sort of.
There's this like a collective ai in,
in the google sort of search,
Google search,
you know the where we're all sort of
plugged in as like,
like nodes on the network,
like leaves on a big tree or in rural
rural feeding this network with our
questions and answers all collectively
programming the ai and the the and
Google plus the older humans that
connect to it are one giant cybernetic
collective.
This is also true of facebook and
twitter and instagram and all these
sorts of networks.
The dryness.
I haven't had a collectives.
Humans and electronics all interfacing
and constantly.
Constantly connected.
Yes,
constantly.
One of the things that I have been
thinking about a lot over the last few
years is that one of the things that
drives a lot of people crazy is how how
many people are obsessed with
materialism and getting the latest
greatest thing and I wonder how much of
that is.
Well,
a lot of it is most certainly fueling
technology and innovation.
It almost seems like it's built into us
to like what we like and what we want,
that we're fueling this thing that's
constantly around us all the time and it
doesn't seem possible that people are
going to pump the brakes.
It doesn't seem possible at this stage
where we're constantly adding new cell
phone,
the latest Tesla update the newest
macbook pro,
but everything has to be newer and
better and that's going to lead to some
incredible point and it seems like it's
built into us.
It almost seems like it's an instinct
that we were working towards this,
that we'd like it our job,
just like the ants build the ant hill.
Our job is to somehow or another fuel
this.
Yes,
I made those comments some some years
ago,
but it feels like we are the biological
bootloader for ai.
Effectively we are building it and then
we're building progressively greater
intelligence and the percentage of
intelligence that is not human is
increasing and eventually we will
represent a very small percentage of
intelligence.
But the,
the AI isn't formed strangely by the
human limbic system.
It is in large part our ed writ large.
How so?
Well,
you mentioned all those things,
the sort of primal drives.
Um,
that's all old things that we like and
hate and fear.
They're all there on the internet,
their projection of our limbic system.
That's true.
Hey,
no,
it makes sense.
Then the thinking of it as a.
let me think of thinking of corporations
and just thinking of just human beings
communicating online through these
social media networks as some sort of an
organism.
That's a,
it's a Cyborg.
It's a combination.
It's a combination of electronics and
biology.
Yeah.
This is in some,
in some measure,
the success of these online systems is
that is sort of a function of,
of how much limbic resonance they're
able to achieve with people.
The more limbic resonance,
the more engagement.
MMM.
Whereas like one of the reasons why
probably instagram is more enticing than
twitter.
Limbic resonance.
Yeah.
You get more images,
more video.
Yes.
Tweaking your system more.
Do you worry about or wonder in fact of
what the next step is?
Me.
A lot of people didn't see twitter
coming that,
you know,
communicating with 140 characters or 280
now would be a thing that people would
be interested in.
Like it's going to excel.
It's gonna become more connected to us,
right?
Yes.
Things are getting more and more
connected there at this point,
constrained by bandwidth.
Our input output is low,
particularly output after got worse with
thumbs and where you sort of input with
10,
10 fingers now if thumbs,
but images are just are also other way
of communicating at high bandwidth.
Take pictures and you send pictures
people sends.
That's,
that communicates far more information
than you can communicate with them.
So what happened with you where you
decided or you took on a more fatalistic
attitude,
like what?
Was there any specific thing or was it
just the inevitability of our future?
I tried to convince people to slow down,
slow down ai to regulate ai.
This was few I tried for years.
See Nobody listened to in a movie.
Robots.
Good fucking take over and you're
freaking me out.
Nobody listened.
Nobody listens.
No one are people more inclined to
listen today.
It seems like an issue that's brought up
more often over the last few years than
it was maybe five,
10 years ago.
It seemed like science fiction,
maybe they will.
So far they haven't.
I think people don't like the.
Normally.
The way the regulations work,
it was very slow,
very slow indeed.
So usually it'll be something.
Some of your technology will cause
damage or death.
There will be an outcry.
They will be an investigation.
You guys will pass.
There will be some sort of insights
committee.
They will be rulemaking than there will
be oversight.
Eventually regulations.
This all takes many years.
This is the normal course of things.
If you look at say what a motive
regulations,
how long did it take for seat belts to
be implemented to be required?
Know the auto industry,
fought seat belts,
I think for more than a decade,
successfully fought any regulations on
seat belts,
even though the numbers were extremely
obvious.
If you had a seatbelt on,
you will be far less likely to die.
It will be certainly entered was
unequivocal and the industry fought this
for years successfully.
Eventually after many,
many people died.
Regulators insisted on seatbelts.
This is a.
This timeframe is not relevant to ai.
You can't take 10 years from the point
at which is dangerous,
so late
and you feel like this is decades away
or years away from being too late.
If you have this fatalistic attitude and
you feel like it's going,
we're in a,
almost like a doomsday countdown.
It's not necessarily a doomsday
countdown.
It's,
it's a out of control.
Countdown
control.
Yeah.
People call it the singularity and uh,
that's,
that's probably a good way to think
about it.
Just,
it's a singular.
It's hard to predict like a black hole,
what happens past the event horizon?
Right?
Sort of once it's implemented,
it's very different because it wants to
get out of the bottle,
what's going to happen and it will be
able to improve itself.
Pro.
Yes.
That's where it gets spooky,
right?
The idea that it can do thousands of
years of innovation.
We're very,
very quickly.
Yeah.
And then we'll be just ridiculous.
Ridiculous.
We will be like this ridiculous
biological shitting pissing thing trying
to stop the gods now stop.
We like,
we like living with a finite lifespan
and watching,
you know,
Norman Rockwell paintings.
It could be terrible and it could be
great.
It's not clear.
Right.
But one thing is for sure we will not
control it.
Do you think that it's likely that we
will merge somehow or another with this
sort of technology and it will augment
what we are now or do you think it will
replace us?
Well,
that's the scenario that the merge
scenario with ai is the one that seems
like probably the best.
Like us.
Yes.
Like if you,
if you can't beat it,
join it.
That's.
Yeah,
you know,
um,
so from a longterm existential
standpoint,
that's like the purpose of neuro link is
to create a high bandwidth interface to
the brain such that we can be somebody
with ai because we have a bandwidth
problem that you just can't communicate
through.
Your fingers is too slow and whereas
neural link at right now,
I think we'll have something interesting
to announce in a few months that's at
least an order of magnitude better than
anything else.
Probably I think better than anyone
thinks is possible.
How much can you talk about that right
now?
I don't want to jump the gun on that.
Um,
but what's like the ultimate,
what's,
what's the idea behind it?
Like what are you trying to accomplish
with it?
Like what would you like best case
scenario?
I think best case scenario we
effectively merge with ai where we ais
serves as a tertiary cognition layer
where we've got the limbic system.
I'm kind of the primitive brain.
Essentially.
You've got the Cortex,
so you're currently in a symbiotic
relationship with your cortex and limbic
system are in a symbiotic relationship
and generally people like their cortex
and they liked the limbic system.
I haven't met anyone who wants to delete
their limbic system or delete their
cortex.
Everybody seems to have like both and
the cortex is mostly in service to the
limbic system.
People may think that that,
that they're,
that they're thinking part of themselves
isn't charged,
but it's mostly their limbic system
that's in charge and the cortex is
trying to make the limbic system happy.
That's what most of that computing power
is,
aren't towards how can I make the limbic
system happy?
That's what I'm trying to do.
Now.
If we do have a third layer,
which is the ai extension yourself,
that is also some biotic,
um,
and there's enough bandwidth between the
cortex and the ai extension of yourself
such that the ai doesn't defacto
separate,
then that could be a good outcome.
That could be quite a positive outcome
for the future.
So instead of replacing us,
it will radically change our
capabilities.
Yes,
it will.
It will enable anyone who wants to have
super human cognition.
Anyone who wants this is not a matter of
earning power because you're earning
power would be vastly greater after you
do it.
So it's just like anyone who wants to
can just do it in theory.
That's the theory.
And,
and if that's the case then and let's
say billions of people do it,
then the outcome for humanity will be
the sum of,
of human will,
some of billions of people's desire for
the future and that,
that Koreans have people with enhanced
cognitive ability radically enhance.
Yes.
And which would be at how much different
than people today.
Like if you,
if you had to explain it to a person who
didn't really know or understand what
you were saying,
like how much different are you talking
about when you say radically improved?
Like what do you mean?
You mean mine read or difficult?
It will be difficult to really
appreciate the difference.
Um,
it was kind like how much smarter are
you with a phone or computer than
without?
It's,
you're vastly smarter.
Actually,
no,
you can answer any question.
If you're connected to the Internet,
you can ask her any question pretty much
instantly,
any calculation,
uh,
the,
that your phone's memory is essentially
perfect.
Uh,
you can remember flawlessly or put your
phone,
can remember videos,
pictures and everything perfectly.
That's the,
that your phone is already an extension
of you.
You're already a Cyborg.
You don't even what most people don't
realize they are already a Cyborg.
If that phone is an extension of
yourself,
it's just that the data rate,
the rate at which was communication rate
between you and the cybernetic extension
of yourself that is your phone and
computer is slow.
It's very slow and that that has like a
tiny straw of,
of,
of information flow between your
biological self and your digital self.
And we need to make that tiny stroll
like a giant river,
huge high bandwidth interface,
interface,
problem,
data rate problem,
solve the data rate problem.
And I think,
I think we can hang onto human machine
symbiosis through the longterm.
And then people may decide that they
want to retain their biological self.
We're not,
I think they'll probably choose to
retain their biological self
versus some sort of Ray Kurzweil
scenario where they download themselves
into a computer.
You will be essentially snapshot it into
a computer at any time.
If your biological self dies,
you could just probably just upload into
a new unit that's really
pass that whiskey.
We're getting crazy over here.
Kind of ridiculous.
Down the rabbit hole.
Grab that software.
Can you tell me that this is too freaky?
See if I've been thinking about this for
a long time.
By the way,
I believe if I was talking to one more
cheers by the way.
Cherished.
Okay.
This is a great whiskey.
Thank you.
Know where this came from.
Who brought this to us?
Trying to remember it.
Somebody gave it to us old camp,
whoever it was.
Thanks.
Good.
Yeah,
it is good.
Um,
this is just inevitable.
Again,
going back to your,
when you decided to have this fatalistic
view points,
so you weren't,
you tried to warn people.
You talked about this pretty
extensively.
I've read several interviews where he
talked about this and then you just sort
of just said,
okay,
just is,
let's just end you in a way.
You're by communicating the potential.
I mean for sure you're getting the
warning out to some people.
Yeah.
I mean I was really going on the warning
quite,
quite a lot.
I was wondering everyone I could you
ever met with Obama and just put one
reason look at?
Yes.
And what did he say?
So what about Hillary?
Worry about her first.
She didn't know he listened.
He certainly listened.
Um,
I met with Congress.
I met with.
I was at a meeting of old 50 governors
and talked about just a ai danger and I
talk to everyone I could.
No one seemed to realize where this was
going.
Is it that or do they just assume that
someone smarter than them is already
taken care of it?
Because when,
when people hear about something like
Ai,
it's almost abstract.
It's almost,
it's almost like it's so.
It's so hard to wrap your head around
it.
By the time it already happens,
it will be too late.
Yeah.
I think they didn't quite understand it
or didn't think it was near term or not
sure what to do about it.
I said like,
you know,
an obvious thing to do is to just
establish a committee governance
committee to gain insight,
you know,
before,
before you oversight,
before you do make regulations they
should like try to understand what's
going on and then if you have an insight
committee
then the,
once they learn what's going on and get
up to speed,
then they can make maybe some roles for
proposed some rules and,
and that would be probably a safer way
to go about things it seems.
I mean I know that it's probably
something that the government supposed
to handle,
but it seems like I wouldn't want the.
I don't want the government to handle
this.
Who Do you want to have one you to
handle?
Oh Geez.
Yeah.
I feel like you're the one who could
ring the bell better because if,
if Mike pence starts talking about Ai,
I'm like,
shut up bitch.
You don't know anything about Ai.
Come up,
man.
He hasn't.
Nobody's talking about anything,
but I don't have the power to regulate
other companies.
What am I supposed to?
Maybe companies could agree.
Maybe good.
There could be some sort of a way.
I mean there's.
We have agreements where you're not
supposed to dump toxic waste into the
ocean.
You're not supposed to do certain
things.
It could be terribly damaging even
though there'll be profitable.
Maybe this is one of those things.
Maybe we should realize that you can't
hit the switch on something that's going
to be able to think for itself and make
up its own mind as to whether or not it
wants to survive or not and whether or
not it thinks you were a threat
and whether or not it thinks you're
useless.
Like why do I keep this dumb,
finite life form alive?
Why?
Why keep this thing around?
It's just stupid.
It's just keeps polluting everything she
ever wear.
Co's,
lighting everything on fire and shooting
each other.
Why would I keep this stupid thing
alive?
Because sometimes it makes good music.
You know?
Sometimes it makes great movies.
Sometimes it makes beautiful art and
sometimes you know,
sometimes it's cool to hang out with my
reasons.
For us,
those are great reasons,
but for anything objective,
standing outside like,
oh,
this is definitely a flawed system.
This is like if you went to the jungle
and you watch these chimps engage in
warfare and beat each other with sticks,
they're fucking really fucking mean.
The real.
So that movie chimpanzee.
Yeah,
that was gonna be like some.
There's anything.
I was like,
holy cow,
what movie was that?
It looks really cool.
Chimpanzee,
who is it?
A documentary?
Yeah.
It's kind of like a documentary.
I was like,
damn,
these chimps are mean.
They're mean,
they're cruel.
They're calculated.
Yeah.
They sneak up on each other and like,
I didn't realize chimps did calculator.
Cruelty.
Yeah.
It's pretty left that meeting.
Kind of like game over.
This is dark,
right?
Well,
we know better because we've advanced,
but if we hadn't,
we'd be like,
man,
I don't want to fucking live in a house.
I like the champ ways,
bro.
Chimp ways to go.
This is it man.
Chimp life right now,
but we in a way to the AI might be like
those chimps,
like these stupid Fox launching missiles
out of drones and shooting each other
underwater.
Like we're crazy.
We got torpedoes,
submarines and fucking airplanes that
drop nuclear bombs indiscriminately on
cities were assholes too.
Yeah.
They might go,
why are they doing this?
It might like,
look at our politics,
look at what we do in terms of our food
system,
what kind of food we forced down each
other's throats,
and they might go this.
These people are crazy.
Didn't even look out for themselves.
I don't know.
How much do we think about chimps?
Not much.
Very little.
It's like these chimps are at war.
They look like groups of chimps just
attack each other and they kill each
other and they torture each other.
That's pretty bad.
Um,
they hunt monkeys there,
but like,
this is probably the most.
But you know,
I mean,
when's the last time we talked about
chimps but me all the time.
If you do talk to the podcast episode,
people are laughing right now.
Yeah,
constantly.
I'm obsessed.
I saw that David attenborough
documentary on Champs when they were
eating those calibus monkeys and ripping
them apart that many,
many years ago,
and it just changed how I go,
Oh,
this is why people are so crazy.
We came from that thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
I got a better philosophy.
They like swingers.
Yeah,
they really are.
They're they.
They seem to be way more even than us.
Way More civilized.
They just seemed to resolve everything
with sex.
The only rules they have as the mom
won't bang the Sun.
That's it.
Okay.
Mom.
I'll bring your sons.
They're good women.
Good women in the community.
Everybody else is banging it out.
Yeah.
I haven't seen the Lenovo movie.
Well,
they're disturbing just at a zoo.
Benobos at the zoo.
They just constantly going constantly.
Fucking boring stuff.
Yeah,
and they don't care.
Gay,
straight,
whatever.
Let's just fuck.
I haven't seen was at a zoo s probably
like the PGA section.
Yeah,
I don't think they have them at many
zoos.
We've looked at it before.
It was probably pretty awkward.
I think that's the thing that they like
to keep regular chimps at zoos because
Benomo was just always jacking off and
what's that they have in San Diego has
got some really interesting,
probably separate them.
How many other in a cage?
It's going to be pretty intense.
We'll go.
Yeah,
we're were a weird thing,
you know,
and I've often wondered if whether or
not we're,
you know,
our ultimate goal is to give birth to
some new thing and that that's why we're
so obsessed with technology because it's
not like this technology is really.
I mean it's certainly enhancing our
lives to in a certain way,
but I mean ultimately is it making
people happier right now?
Most technology I would say no.
In fact,
you and I were talking about social
media before this,
about just not having instagram on your
phone and not dealing with you feel
better.
Yes.
I think that one of the issues with
social media that's been pointed out by
many people is that,
um,
I think maybe particularly instagram,
people look like they have a much better
life than they really do.
Right?
So by design.
Yeah.
People are posting pictures of when they
were really happy there are modifying
those pictures to be better looking if
they're not modifying the pictures
there,
at least selecting the pictures for the
best lighting,
the best angle.
So people basically seem I'll,
they're way better looking than they
basically really are.
And they're way happier seeming than
they really are.
So if you look at everyone on Instagram,
you might think,
man,
they're always happy,
beautiful people and I'm not that good
login and I am not happy,
so I must suck,
you know.
And that's gonna make people sad.
So when in fact those people you think
are super happy,
actually not that happy.
Some of them are really depressed.
They're very sad.
So my happiest people actually some of
the saddest people in reality.
Um,
and,
and nobody looks good all the time.
It doesn't matter who you are.
No,
it's not even something you should want.
Why do you want to look great all the
time.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
uh,
so I think,
I think things like that can make people
quite sad when you just,
just by comparison because you,
you just sort of,
you people,
people generally think of themselves
relative to others.
It's,
it's,
uh,
we're constantly re,
we baselining our expectations.
Um,
and you can see the,
if you watch some show like naked and
afraid or if you're just going to try
living in the woods by yourself for
awhile in,
you,
like the learn that civilization was
quite great.
It has a lot of people want to come back
to civilization pretty fast on naked and
afraid.
Wasn't that a thoreau quote?
The comparison is the thief of joy of
happiness is reality minus expectations.
That's great too.
But the comparison is the thief of joy
really holds true to peep.
Is it they don't.
Roosevelt Roosevelt Fascinating,
um,
in,
when you think about instagram,
because would essentially instagram is
with a lot of people is you're giving
them the opportunity to be their own pr
agent and they always go towards the
glamorous,
you know,
and whenever anybody does show Hashtag
no filter,
they have,
they really do do that.
Like,
oh,
you're so brave.
Look,
you don't make up now they look good.
Anyway.
You look great.
What are you doing?
Oh my God.
You don't have makeup on and still a hot
as fuck.
You know what you're doing.
I know what you're doing to.
They're there.
They're letting you know and then the
feed off that comment section.
Woo.
Just a little bit sitting there like,
look,
it's a fresh stream of love,
like you getting right up to the sources
that comes out of the earth and just
suck in that water.
Emojis,
emojis.
Yeah.
A lot of allergies.
My what?
My concern is not so much what instagram
is,
is that I didn't think that people had
the need for this or the expectation for
some sort of technology that allows them
to constantly get love and adulation
from strangers and comments and this
ability to project this sort of
distorted version of who you really are,
but I worry about where it goes.
Like what's the next one?
What's the next one?
Like,
where is it?
Is it going to be augmented in some sort
of a weird augmented or virtual sort of
instagram type situation where you're
not going to want to live in this real
world,
you're going to want to interface with
this sort of world that you've created
through your social media page and some
next level thing.
Go live in the simulation?
Yeah,
maybe in the simulation ready player one
type shit that's real.
That seems.
We have that htc vive here and I've only
done it a couple times quite honestly
because it kind of freaks me out.
My kids fucking love it,
man.
They love it.
They love playing these Weirdo Games and
walking around with that headset on.
But part of me watching them do it goes,
wow,
I wonder if this is like the precursor,
just sort of like if you look at that
phone,
that Gordon Gekko hat on the beach and
compare that to like a galaxy note nine.
Like how the fuck did that become that?
Right?
And I wonder when I see this htc vive
and my,
what is that thing gonna be 10 years
from now when we're making fun of what
it is now,
what is it?
How?
I mean,
how ingrained and how,
how,
how connected and interconnected is this
technology going to be in our life?
It will be at some point
indistinguishable from reality
where we'll lose this or lose this.
Like you and I just looked at each other
through our eyes.
I see you where you see me,
I think.
I hope you think so.
I think you probably have read it.
Regularize.
This could be some simulation.
It could.
Do you entertain that?
Well,
the argument for the simulation I think
is quite strong because if you assume
any improvements at all over time,
any improvement,
one percent point one percent.
Just extend the timeframe.
Make it a thousand years,
a million years.
The Universe is 13 point 8 billion years
old.
What civilization,
if you counted,
if you're very generous,
civilization is maybe seven or 8,000
years old.
If you counted from the first writing.
This is nothing.
So if you assume any rate of improvement
at all,
then games will be indistinguishable
from reality or civilization
will end one of those two things will
occur.
We are most likely in a simulation
or we're on our way,
right?
Well,
we could most certainly be on the road.
We could be on the road,
did that,
right?
It doesn't mean that it has to face
reality.
It could be in base reality.
We could be here now on our way to the
road or on her way to the destination
where this can never happen again,
where we are completely ingrained in
some sort of an artificial technology or
some sort of a symbiotic relationship
with the internet or the next level of
sharing information.
But right now we're not there yet.
That's possible too,
right?
It's possible that a simulation is one
day going to be inevitable,
that we're going to have something
that's indistinguishable from regular
reality,
but maybe we're not there yet.
That's also possible.
We're not quite there yet.
That this is real.
When I touched that feels very real.
Maybe that's why everybody's like
getting to like mason jars and shit.
Mason's suede shoes people wear to like
craft restaurants and they wouldn't want
raw wood.
Everyone says everyone else.
See Metal people.
It seems like people are like longing
toward some weird log cabin type.
Nostalgia reality.
Yeah.
Like holding on like clinging to her,
dragging their nails through the mud.
Like don't take me a yes,
but then.
But then people will go get a mason jar
with the Weinstein or handle
that's dark.
Makes me lose faith in humanity.
Wind Stamina,
handle.
They have those.
Oh that's dirty.
People are just assholes.
That's like,
people make pet rocks rough.
Right?
There's some people are just assholes.
They take advantage of our,
our,
our generous nature.
It was made with the Weinstein made with
handle.
They made it that way.
So the,
onto the mace.
Ah,
you thought that would be fine if there
was like glued it on or something,
but it was made that way.
White trash chic.
Oh,
this is disgusting.
This.
Here it is right there.
Yup.
This is terrible.
Yeah.
That's like fake breasts that are
designed to be hard.
Like fake breasts from the sixties.
It's like if you really long for the
ones with ripples,
here we go.
Yeah.
That's almost what that is.
What are you going to do,
man?
It's not nothing.
It's not need to stop certain terrible
ideas from propagating.
Yeah.
Um,
anyway,
I,
I don't want to sound like,
like thanks for too dark because I think
like,
you kind of have to
be optimistic about the future.
There's no point in being pessimistic.
It's just too negative.
Does this,
it doesn't help,
you know,
I think you want to be.
I mean,
my theory is like you'd rather be
optimistic.
I think I'd rather be optimistic and
wrong than pessimistic and.
Right.
Police around that side.
Yeah.
Because if,
if you're pessimistic is going to be as
miserable.
Yeah.
And nobody wants to be around you
anyway.
If it's the end of the world,
you know,
like I told you,
Bro.
Yeah.
The world's ending.
It is what it is.
Enjoy the journey.
Right?
If you really want to get morose,
I mean,
it is what it is for all of us anyway.
We were all going to go unless something
changes.
Yeah,
I mean ultimately,
you know,
even if we just sort of existed as
humans forever,
we'd be with still eventually,
that'd be like the heat death of the
universe,
right?
Israelian years from now,
right now if we get it past the sun,
if we figured out a way past the son
running out of juice,
eventually it's going to end.
It's just a question of when.
Right?
So it really is all about the journey or
transcendence from whatever we are now
into something that doesn't worry about
death.
The universe as we know it will
dissipate into a fine mist of cold.
Nothing this eventually,
and then someone's going to bottle it
and put a fragrance to it,
sell it to French people in another
dimension.
So it's a very long time.
So I think it's really just about how
can we make it last longer.
Are you a proponent of the multiuniverse
theory?
Do you believe that there are many,
many universes and that even if this one
fades out,
that there's other ones that are
starting fresh right now and there's an
infinite number of them,
they're just constantly in this never
ending cycle of birth and death.
I think most likely,
this is just about probability.
There are many,
many simulations,
these simulations or we might as well
call them reality or you could call them
the multiverse.
These simulations you believe are
created like someone has managed running
on a substrate,
so that substrate is probably boring,
boring.
How so?
Well,
when we create a simulation like a game
or a movie,
it's a distillation of what's
interesting about life.
You know,
like it,
it takes,
it can take a year to shoot an action
movie and then that's all distilled down
into two or three hours.
So let me tell you,
if you see an action movie being filmed,
frigging boring,
super boring takes.
There's lots of takes those.
Everything's in a green screen,
looks pretty goofy,
doesn't look cool,
but once you add the CGI and have great
editing,
it's amazing.
So I think most likely if we're a
simulation,
it's really boring outside the
simulation because why would you make
simulation that's boring because it
makes simulation way more interesting in
the base reality that is if this right
now is a simulation and ultimately
inevitably we're,
if as long as we don't die or get hit by
a meteor,
we're going to create some sort of
simulation if we continue on the same
technological path we're on,
we're on right now,
but we might not be there yet.
So it might not be a simulation here,
but it most likely is you feel other
places,
this notion of place or where is a
flawed,
flawed perception like that if you have
this sort of,
but a vive,
which that's made by valve and steam and
it's really valve that made it.
HDC did the hardware,
but it's really evolved thing.
Um,
makers of Halflife yes,
a great company.
Great Company.
Hmm.
Uh,
when you're in that,
in that,
in that virtual reality,
which is only going to get better,
where are you?
Where are you really?
Right?
You aren't anywhere.
Well,
whereas in the computer,
what you know,
what defines where you are exactly
right.
It's your perception is your perceptions
or is it a scale that we have under your
butt.
You right here,
I've measured you.
You're the same weight as you were when
you left.
Meanwhile you're experienced.
Do you think you're where you are right
now?
You might not be.
I'll spark up a joint.
If you keep talking to your manager's
gonna,
come in here.
We might have to lock the door right
now.
You think you're in a studio in la?
That's what I heard.
You might be in a computer.
Oh,
medicine.
Man,
I think about this all the time.
Yeah,
I mean it's unquestionable that one day
that'll be the case.
As long as we keep going,
as long as nothing interrupts us,
and if we start from scratch and you
know we're single celled organisms all
over again and then millions and
millions of years later would become the
next thing that is us with creativity
and the ability to change the
environment.
It's going to keep monkeying with things
until it figures out a way to change
reality to change,
I mean almost like punch a hole through
what is this thing into what,
what it wants it to be and create new
things and then those new things will
intersect with other people's new things
and then it will be this ultimate
pathway of infinite ideas and expression
all through technology.
Yeah.
And then we're wondering,
we're going to wonder like why are we
here?
What are we doing?
Let's find out why.
I mean,
I think we should take the actions,
the set of actions that are most likely
to make the future better.
Yes.
Right.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
And then reevaluate those actions to
make sure that they're there.
That it's true.
Well,
I think there's a movement to that.
I mean,
in terms of like a social movement,
I think some of it's misguided and some
of it's exaggerated and there's a Lotta,
a lot of people that are fighting for
their side out there,
but it seems like the general trend of
like a social awareness seems to be much
more heightened now than it's ever been
in any other time in history because of
our ability to express ourselves
instantaneously to each other through
facebook or twitter or what have you,
and that the trend is to abandon
preconceived notions,
abandoned prejudice,
abandoned discrimination,
and promote kindness and happiness as
much as possible.
Looking at this knife.
Somebody gave it to me.
Sorry.
What the fuck did you do?
My friend Dani.
I brought this with him and it just
stayed here.
I have a real Samurai sword.
Fun To play with that.
I know you're into weapons.
That's from the 15 hundreds.
Samurais or at the end of the table.
Yeah.
That's cool.
I'll grab it.
Hold on.
Yeah,
that's a Legit Samurai sword from an
actual Samurai from the 15 hundreds.
If you pull out that blade,
that bleed was made the old way.
Where a master craftsman folded that
metal and hammered it down over and over
again over a long period of time and
honed that blade into what it is now.
What's crazy is that more than 500 years
later,
that thing is still pristine.
I mean,
whoever took care of that and pass it
down to the next person who took care of
it and you know,
til it got to the podcast room,
it's pretty fucking crazy.
Yeah.
One day someone's going to be looking at
a tesla like that [inaudible].
He's fucking back doors.
They pop up sideways like a Lamborghini.
You should see what tesla can do.
Uh,
you didn't.
You should.
I'll show you after driven one.
I love them.
Yeah.
But most people don't know what it can
do in terms of like ludicrous mode in
terms of like driving super fast and
irresponsibly on public roads is that
were saying why do you call it can do
that.
Yeah.
What can it do that,
that I need to know about having the
model x can do this like ballet thing to
the Trans Siberian orchestra.
It's pretty cool.
We're at dances if legitimately like
moves you out to that.
Why would you program that seemed like
fun.
That's what I get about you.
That's what's weird.
Like when you showed up here,
you were all smiles and you pull out a
fucking blow torch and not a blow torch,
but I'm like looking at the flame
thrower,
not a flame thrower,
Mike.
It's definitely not like you're having
fun.
Like this is a like this thing when you
know your program,
a car to do a ballet,
dance,
fun.
How do you have the time to do that?
I don't understand why you're digging
holes under the earth.
Incentive rockets into space and and
power in people in Australia.
Like how the fuck do you have time to
make the car dance ballet?
Well,
I mean,
in that case there were some engineers
at Tesla that said,
you know what?
If we make this car dance and play
music,
I was like,
that sounds great.
Let's do it.
Let's try to get it done in time.
For Christmas.
We did.
Is there a concern about someone just
losing their mind and making do that in
the highway?
Now it wouldn't do that.
What if it's in bumper to bumper
traffic?
Nope.
No,
won't do it.
Nope.
It's actually you have to just an Easter
egg.
Oh,
it's an Easter egg.
That's why people don't know about it.
You put it here.
We'll have the car.
It can do lots of things.
Lots of things.
Once reddit gets a hold of it,
everyone's,
Oh,
you just have to everyone.
If you search for it on the Internet,
you will find out.
But people don't know that they should
even search for it.
Oh,
well they do now.
Yes.
There's so many things about the model x
and the model s and the model three that
people don't know about.
We should probably do a video or
something it and explain it because I
have close friends of mine and I say,
do you know the call can do this?
And they're like,
nope.
Do you want to do a video though?
Do you like the fact that some people
don't know?
No,
I think it's probably not.
We should tell people.
Yeah,
probably.
Yes.
That would help your product.
I mean,
it's not like you don't sell enough of
them,
you sell almost too many of them.
Right.
The,
I mean I think at Tesla is the most fun
thing you could possibly buy ever.
That's what it's meant to be.
Well,
our goal is to make.
It's,
it's not exactly a car.
It's actually a thing to maximize
enjoyment.
Make maximum fun.
Okay.
Electronic like big screen,
laptop,
ridiculous speed handling,
all that stuff.
Yeah.
Do you have.
And you're going to put video games in
it?
You are?
Yeah.
Is this wise?
Well,
what you won't be able to drive while
you're playing the video game,
but we're like,
for example,
we just,
we're just putting the,
the Atari emulator rom memory later in
it,
so we'll play missile command and Lunar
Lander and a bunch of other things.
Oh yeah,
that sounds cool.
It's pretty fun.
I like that.
Yeah.
And we improved the interface of missile
command because it's too hard with the
old track bull.
So this is the touchscreen version of
missile command.
So you have a chance.
Do you have an old car?
Don't you?
Don't you have like an old Jaguar?
Yeah.
That.
That's.
That's a 61 series.
Warranty type Jagger.
I love cars.
It's great.
Yeah.
I love old cars.
The only two,
only two.
Your gasoline cars I have about that.
And,
and
old Ford,
like a Ford model t that a friend of
mine gave me my only to gasoline cars is
the Ford model t all stock.
Well there's your car.
Ooh,
look ahead with the convertible.
That is a gorgeous.
Our God.
That's a good looking car.
Yes.
Is that yours?
That is.
It's not mine.
It's extremely close to mine that I
don't have a front license plate or
mine.
Oh,
that's a beautiful car.
They knew that.
That's mine.
Looks like that.
God.
They nailed that.
That's what mine looks like.
Very good.
Is Money.
There's certain iconic shapes.
Yes.
And there's,
there's something about those cars too.
They're not as capable,
not nearly as capable as like a tesla,
but there's something really satisfying
about the mechanical aspect of feeling
the steering and the grinding of the
gears and the shifting.
There's something about those that's
extremely satisfying even though they're
not that competent.
Like I have a 19,
93 porsche nine slash six four.
It's like a lightweight.
It's not as rs America.
It's not very fast.
It's not like in comparison to a tesla
or anything like that,
but the thing about it is like it's
mechanical feel of everything.
It's.
It gives you this weird thrill,
like you're on this clinky ride and this
all this feedback.
There's something to that.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
yeah,
one type is like basically no
electronics.
It's just you like that,
but you also like electronics.
Yes.
Like your teslas soup.
It's like the far end of electronics.
Yes.
Drives itself.
It's driving itself better every day.
Yeah.
It's like we're about to release the
software that will enable you to just
turn it on and it'll drive from highway
on,
ramp to a highway,
exit through lane changes to overtake
other cars to go from one interchange
the next.
If you get on,
say the four or five,
get off,
get off 300 miles later and go through
several highway interchanges and to
overtake other cars and hook into the
NAV system.
And then um,
and you just meditating.
Oh
yeah.
Because just traveling very kind of
eerie kind of eerie.
What did you think when you saw that
video?
That dude fallen asleep behind the wheel
and I'm sure you've seen it.
The one in San Francisco is like,
right outside of San Jose,
out cold like this and the car
interpreter bumper traffic moving along.
Or have you seen it right?
Yeah,
yeah,
we changed the software.
That's I think an old video which has
software where if,
if you don't touch the wheel,
it will gradually slow down and put the
emergency lights on and wake you up.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
Can you choose what voice wakes you up?
Well,
it sort of more of a.
it's sort of honks honking.
This should be like wake up fuck face.
Well,
bringing your fellow humans.
We could,
we could gently wake you up with a
sultry voice.
Oh,
that would be good.
Like a,
something with a southern accent.
Hey,
why can't wake up sunshine?
Hey Sweetie.
Thank you.
Exactly.
Why don't you wake like,
pick.
You could pick your right like you want.
Yeah.
I choose the Australian girl for Siri.
Take her voice.
Do you want it to seductive?
Favorite Australian?
What?
Flavor of do what you want it to be
angry.
It could be anything.
You want those Australian prison lady
genes.
Now when you,
um,
when you program something like that in,
is this in response to a concern or is
it your own?
If you look at it and go,
Hey,
I'm.
They shouldn't just be able to fall
asleep.
Wake him up.
Yeah.
We like know,
we're like,
well,
you know,
people falling asleep.
We were about to do something about
that.
Right?
But when you first released it,
you didn't consider it,
right?
You just like,
well no one's going to just sleep.
People fall asleep in cars all the time.
Let's crash.
Yeah.
At least our car doesn't crash.
That's better.
It's better not to crash.
Imagine if that God falling asleep in a,
in a gasoline car.
They do all the time for sure.
Yeah.
And it crashed and somebody.
And in fact,
the thing that really got me to,
it's like,
man,
we better get on autopilot going get it
out.
There was a guy who was in an early
Tesla driving down the highway and he
fell asleep and he ran over a cyclist
and killed them and cycles like,
man,
if we had the autopilot wouldn't run out
of the one.
He might have fallen asleep,
but at least he wouldn't run over that
cyclist.
So how did you implement it?
Like did you just use cameras in
programmed with the,
the,
the system so that if it sees images it
slows down.
And how much time do you give as the
person who's in control of it allowed to
program how fast it goes?
Yes.
Yeah.
You can program it to be more or less
like more conservative or more
aggressive driver.
Um,
and uh,
you can say what speed you want it to,
what,
what speed is.
Okay.
I know you have ludicrous mode.
Do you have douchebag mode?
Well,
it was just cuts people off well for
four lane changes.
That's tricky because if you're in like
La,
like in last year,
pretty aggressive,
right?
It's pretty.
It's hard to change lanes sometimes.
It's hard to be sot nom.
It's hard to be numb day on here in La.
You get,
if you want to hit that Santa Monica
Boulevard off ramp.
I mean you got to be a little pushy.
You got to be a little pushy.
Yeah.
Especially if you're angry,
a little angry.
They don't want you in this speed up
sometimes.
You know.
I think people like overall a pretty
nice when the highway even in la,
but sometimes they're not.
Do you think the neurological health
that probably everybody would
be locked in together as hive?
Mind tunnels will help it.
We're going to have traffic that'll help
a lot.
Yeah.
How many of those can you put in there?
That's a nice thing about tunnels as you
can go through Edi.
So many levels.
Right?
So until you hit hell.
Yeah,
but you could go.
You could have 100 levels of tunnel.
Their bombs.
Jesus Christ.
I don't want to be a 99 man.
It'd be the 99th,
negative 99 floors.
Cool.
This is one of the fundamental things
people don't appreciate about tunnels is
that there's not like roads.
The fundamental issue with roads is that
you have a tutee transport system and a
three d living in workspace environment.
So you've got all these tall buildings
or,
or concentrated work environments and,
and then then you want to go into this
like tootie transport system,
which usually in a pretty low density
because cars are spaced out pretty far.
Um,
and,
and so that obviously is not going to
work.
You're going to have traffic guaranteed.
But if you can go three D on your
transport system,
then you can solve all traffic and you
can either go 3d up with a flying car or
can go through ed down with tunnels and
you can have as many tunnel levels as
you want and you can arbitrarily relieve
any amount of traffic.
You can go further down with tunnels.
Then you can go up with buildings.
You're 10,000
feet down if you want.
I wouldn't recommend it,
but what was that movie with?
What's his face?
The Bradley Cooper.
Not Bradley Cooper.
A Christian.
Now what the fuck is his name?
Who Was Batman?
Christian Bale.
Where he.
They fought dragons.
Him and Matthew Mcconaughey went down
deep into the earth.
How high?
How deep can you go up man,
but yeah,
it was.
It was meant for dragons.
Batman,
but Christian Bale Reign.
A fire ring of fire.
Never saw that.
No,
but good.
I wouldn't recommend saying super far
down.
Right?
Molten.
We're.
Yeah.
Earth is a giant bowl of lava
with a thin crust on the top,
which we think of as like the surface,
this thin crust and it's mostly just a
big ball of lava
that's earth,
but 10,000
feet.
It's not a big deal.
Have you given any consideration
whatsoever to the flat Earth Movement
thought?
I think that's a troll situation.
Oh,
it's not.
No,
You would like to think because you're a
super genius,
but I as a normal,
normal person,
I know there's people way dumber than me
and they really,
really believe.
They watch youtube videos which go on
uninterrupted and spew out a bunch of
fucking fake vacs very eloquently and
articulately and they really believe
these people.
Really.
I mean,
if it works for them,
sure,
fine,
fine.
Weird that right.
That in this age where you know it was
ludicrous mode and your car goes one
point nine seconds.
Zero to 62 point two,
two point two.
Which one's one point nine?
The poster.
The next generation roadster.
Certain standard edition.
Yeah.
I'm on top of this shit.
That's the standard edition.
So throughout the performance package,
what performance package?
What the fuck do you need me to put
rocket thrusters on it?
For Real?
What are they going to burn?
I think high ultra high pressure.
Compressed air.
Well,
just cold gas thrusters new.
Do you have to have air tanks?
Are they sucking the air out?
Okay?
Yeah,
just electric pump.
Whoa.
Pump it up like 10,000
PSI.
And how fast are we talking?
Zero to 60.
How fast you want to go to go?
Could make it fly.
I want to go back in time to make it
fly.
You make it fly?
Sure.
Do you anticipate that as being me,
you were talking about the tunnels and
then flying cars,
do you really think that's going to be
real too noisy and this too much air
flow so that the fundamental issue with
flying cars,
I mean I forget what one of those like
toy drones,
I think of how much,
how loud those are and how much air
that.
How much air they blow.
Now imagine if that's like a thousand
times heavier.
This is not going to be make your
neighbors happy.
Your neighbors are not going to be
happy.
If you land a flying car in your
backyard,
it will be very helicopter or on your
roof.
They're just really going to be like,
what the hell that it was annoying.
You can't even look.
If you want a flying car,
just put some wheels on a helicopter.
Is there a way around that?
Like what if they figure out some sort
of magnetic technology,
like all those Bob Lazard type
characters were thinking that was a part
of the UFO technology they were doing at
area 51.
Remember,
didn't they have some,
some thoughts about magnetics?
Nope,
no bullshit.
Yes.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a fundamental momentum exchange
with the air,
so you must.
You must accelerate your business like
this.
There's a certain.
You have a mess and you have gravity,
gravitational acceleration and mass mass
times your mass times gravity must equal
the massive air flow times the
acceleration of that f flow to have a
neutral force,
so it's impossible to go around and then
you won't move.
If FMG is greater than you will go down
and if mas greater than mg you will go
up.
That's how it works.
There's just no way around that.
There is definitely no way around it.
There's no way to create some sort of a
magnetic something or another that
allows you to technically yes,
you you could have a strong enough
magnet,
but that magnet would be strong,
that you would create a lot of trouble.
We just suck cars up in your car.
Just pickup.
I mean,
you'd have to repel off of either a
material on the ground or in a really
nasty situation off of Earth's
gravitational field and somehow make
that incredibly light,
but that magnet would cause so much
destruction.
You'd be better off with a helicopter.
So if there was some sort of magnet
road,
like you have two magnets and they repel
each other.
If you had some sort of a magnet road
that was below you and you could travel
on that magnet road,
that would work.
Yes.
You could have a magnet road,
a magnet road because that too.
Ridiculous.
No,
it's ridiculous to.
Right.
I would not recommend it.
There's a lot of things I don't
recommend or not recommend that not
good.
Not Wise.
I think no roads.
No,
no that.
definitely not.
Definitely not.
I was good.
I would cause a lot of trouble.
So you've put some time and
consideration into this other than,
you know,
instead of like my foolishly rendered
thoughts.
So you think that tunnels of the way to
do it?
Oh,
it'll work for sure.
That'll work.
Yes.
And your,
these,
these tunnels that you're building right
now,
these are basically just like test
versions of this ultimate idea that you
have,
you know,
it's just a hole in the ground,
right?
We played videos of it where you're
going to drop that hole in the ground,
there's a sled on it and the sled goes
very fast.
Like 100 miles an hour plus.
Yeah,
you can go real fast,
fast as you want.
And then if you want to go long
distances you can just grow the air out
of the tunnel,
make sure it's real straight.
Draw the air of the tunnel.
Yeah.
So vacuum tunnel,
um,
because the.
And then depending on how fast you wanna
go,
you can either use wheels or you could
use air bearings depending upon the
ambient pressure in the tunnel.
Or You could a maglev it if you want to
go super fast.
So magnet road,
yes,
but underground magnet roads,
underground magnet,
otherwise you're going to really create
a lot of trouble with because those
metal things.
So magnet rose the way to go.
Just underground.
Do you want to go really fast?
Underground?
You would be in a,
you would be maglev in a vacuum tunnel,
mag in a vacuum tunnel,
magnetic levitation in a backroom,
tunnel entrance.
Fun with rocket launchers.
Now I would not recommend putting any
exhaust gas in the tunnel.
Oh,
okay.
I see what you're saying because then
you have to pump it on,
right?
You have to pump it out and you probably
have a limited amount of air in the
first place.
Like how much can you breathe?
Do you have to pump oxygen into these
cubicles of the pressurized pod and be
like,
like a little tiny underground.
Basically
like an airplane because you have a or
an airplane.
It's not getting new Aaron.
It is.
It is,
yes.
We have like a little hole.
Yeah,
they have a pump.
Really?
Yeah.
It gets it from the outside.
Yes.
Wow.
I didn't know that was like,
it's the airplanes have it.
Have it easy because essentially you
can.
They're pretty leaky but Jesus.
Yeah,
but so long as they.
As long as the air pump is working at a
decent speed,
they have backup pumps.
Still have like three pumps to four
pumps or something and uh,
and then that,
then there's like,
there's,
it exhausts through the outflow valve
and,
and through whatever seals are not
feeling quite right.
Usually the door doesn't feel quite
right on a plane.
This was a bit of leakage around the
door and uh,
but the,
the pumps a exceed the flow rate and
then that sets the pressure in the,
in the cabin.
Now,
have you ever looked at and gone,
I can fix this,
but I just don't have time as you make
them a design for a plane,
you do a better design.
I mean probably I think it is.
Well,
have you talked to about this and I've
talked to friends,
friends,
friends and family,
girlfriends,
and you can tell me what do you got?
What's going on?
Well,
I mean the exciting thing to do would be
some sort of electric vertical takeoff
and landing supersonic,
jet up,
some kind of vertical takeoff and
landing mean no need for runway.
Just shoot up straight in the air and
then,
Ooh,
how'd you do that?
When they do that and some military
aircrafts,
correct?
Yes.
The trick is that you have,
you have to transition to level flight
and then you the the,
the thing that you'd use for vertical
Tafe will take over and landing is not
suitable for high speed flight,
so you have two different systems where
thought about this quite a lot.
The interesting thing about an electric
plane is that you want to go as high as
possible,
but you need a certain energy density in
the battery pack because you have to
overcome gravitational potential energy.
Once you've overcome gravitational
potential energy and you're at at at at
a high altitude,
the energy use in cruise is very low and
then you could recapture a large part of
your,
the gravitational potential energy on
the way down.
So you really don't need any kind of
reserve fuel,
if you will,
because you have the,
the energy of height,
gravitational potential energy.
This is a lot of energy.
So.
So once you can get high the high you
like the way to think about a plane,
it is.
It's a force balance to the force
balance.
So a plane that is not accelerating,
um,
is,
is a neutral force balance at the force
of gravity.
If the lift force with the wings,
then you've got the force of the one of
the thrusting device,
so the propeller or turbine or whatever
it is,
and you've got the resistance force of
the air.
Now the higher you go,
the lower the error assistance.
Yes,
air density drops exponentially,
but drag increases with the square and
exponential beats of square.
The higher you go,
the faster you will go for the same
amount of energy
and at a certain altitude you can go
supersonic with less energy per mile,
quite a lot less energy per mile.
Then an aircraft at 35,000
feet because it's just a force balance.
I'm just doing it for this conversation.
It makes sense.
No,
I'm sure it does.
Now,
when you think about this new idea of,
of,
of designing it,
when,
when you have this idea about improving
planes,
are you going to bring this to somebody
or you just chuck a lot on my plate,
right?
This what I'm saying?
I don't know.
I don't know how you do what you do now,
but if you keep coming up with these,
but it's got to be hard to pawn this off
on someone else,
either a,
hey,
go do a job.
A good job with this vertical takeoff
and landing system that I want to
implement into regular planes.
They're playing electric airplane isn't
necessarily right now.
Electric cars are important and we need
to source energy is important.
Stationary storage of energy is
important.
These things are much more important
than creating electric supersonic,
fetal.
Also,
the planes naturally you really want
that gravitational energy density for an
aircraft.
Um,
and this is improving over time.
So it's important that we accelerate the
transition to sustainable energy.
That's why electric cars and matters,
whether electric cars happen sooner or
later,
you know,
we're,
we're really playing the crazy game here
with the atmosphere or the oceans were
taking vast amounts of carbon from deep
ground and putting this,
putting this neat and the atmosphere was
crazy.
We should not do this.
It's very dangerous.
So we should,
we should,
we should accelerate the transition to
sustainable energy.
I mean this,
the bizarre thing is that obviously
we're going to run out of oil in long
term.
You know,
we're going to.
There's only so much oil we can.
We can mine it burn.
It's total logical.
We must have to sustainable energy,
transport and energy infrastructure in
the longterm so we know that's the end
point.
We know that.
So why I run this crazy experiment where
we take trillions of tons of carbon from
underground and put it in the atmosphere
and oceans.
This isn't insane experiment.
It's the dumbest experiment in human
history.
Why are we doing this?
It's crazy.
Do you think this is a product of
momentum that we started off doing this
when it was just a few engines,
a few hundred million gallons of fuel
over the whole world,
not that big of a deal and then slowly
but surely over a century it got out of
control and now it it.
It's not just our fuel,
but it's also the fossil fuels are
involved in so many different
electronics,
so many different items that people buy.
It's just this constant desire for
fossil fuels,
constant need for oil,
without consideration of the
sustainability thing is like oil,
oil,
coal,
gas will the easy money.
It's easy money.
So have you heard about clean coal?
The president's been tweeting about.
It's got to be real clean coal.
All caps.
Did you see he used all caps,
clean coal.
Um,
well,
you know,
it's very difficult to put that CEO to
back in the ground.
It doesn't like being in solid form.
Have you thought about energy like that?
Like some sort of a filter,
giant building sized filter socks,
carbon out of the atmosphere.
Is that possible?
No.
No,
he doesn't talk possible.
Nope.
No,
nope.
Definitely not fucked.
No,
we're not fucked.
I mean,
this is a quite a complex question,
right?
You know,
we're really just,
when the more carbon we take out of the
ground and add to the atmosphere and a
lot of it gets permeated into the
oceans,
the more dangerous it is.
Like I don't think right now.
I think we're okay right now.
We can probably even add some more,
but the momentum towards sustainable
energy is too slow like that.
There's a vast base of industry,
vast transportation system like this,
this two and a half billion cars and
trucks in the world,
so and,
and,
and the,
the new car and truck production.
If it was 100 percent electric,
that's only about $100 million per year.
So it would take,
if you could snap your fingers and
instantly turn all old cars and trucks,
electric,
it would still take 25 years to change
the transport based to electric.
Makes sense because how long does it
truck car truck last before it goes into
the junkyard and gets crushed about 20
to 25 years.
Is there a way to accelerate that
process,
like some sort of subsidies or some
encouragement from the government
financially?
Well,
the thing that is going on right now is
that there is an inherit subsidy in any
oil burning device.
Any,
any power plant or car is fundamentally
a consuming the carbon capacity of the
oceans and atmosphere or just say
atmosphere for short.
Um,
so like you can say like,
okay,
there's a certain probability of
something bad happening past a certain
carbon concentration in the atmosphere,
and so there's some uncertain number
where if we put too much carbon in the
atmosphere,
things overheat,
a oceans warm up,
ice caps melt,
ocean real estate becomes a lot less
valuable underwater.
And,
but it's not clear what that number is,
but it's definitely a scientists with
all.
It's really quite the scientists.
The scientific consensus is
overwhelming.
I'm overwhelming.
I mean,
I don't know any serious scientists,
actually zero,
literally zero who don't think that,
you know,
that.
But we have quite a serious climate risk
that we're facing.
And so that's fundamentally a subsidy
occurring with every fossil fuel burning
thing,
power plants per aircraft car.
Frankly,
even rockets rockets use,
uh,
you know,
they burn,
they burn fuel,
but there's just,
you know,
with rockets,
there's just no other way to get to
orbit unfortunately.
So it's the only way.
But with cars there's definitely a
better way with electric cars and to
generate the energy,
do so with multiple tax because we've
got a giant.
Then when you clear reactor in the sky
called the sun,
it's great sort of shows I've everyday
very reliable.
So if you can generate energy from solar
panels stored with batteries,
you can have energy 24 hours a day,
um,
and then you can,
you know,
consented to the polls ordinate near to
the north,
uh,
with know high voltage lines.
Also,
the north,
northern,
northern parts of the world tend to have
a lot of hydropower as well.
Um,
but anyway,
that all fossil fuel power things have
an inherent subsidy which is their
consumption of the carbon capacity of
the atmosphere and oceans.
So people tend to think of like,
why?
Why should electric vehicles have a
subsidy?
But they're not taking into account.
That's all fossil fuel book burning
vehicles fundamentally are subsidized by
cost,
the environmental cost to earth,
but nobody's paying for it.
We are going to pay for it.
Obviously in the future we will pay for
it.
It's just not paid for now.
Now,
what is the bottleneck in regards to
electric cars and trucks and things like
that?
Is it battery capacity?
Yeah,
I've got a scale up production.
Got To make the car compelling,
make it better than gasoline or diesel
cars.
Make it more efficient in terms of like
the distance it can travel.
Yeah.
You got to be able to go far,
far enough,
recharge fast.
And you're roadster,
you're,
you're anticipating 600 miles.
Is that correct?
Yeah.
Yeah,
we,
what is it,
600 mile right now,
like if you driven one 600 miles now?
No,
we can totally make one right now that
will do 600 miles.
But the thing is too expensive,
so it's like the cars but it's more so.
Well just have a 200 kilowatt hour
battery pack and you can go 600 miles.
What do you have now?
Three hundred and 30 mile range,
but that's what does that in terms of
kilowatts?
Well that would be for a model s a 100
kilowatt hour pack.
We'll do about 330 miles,
maybe 3:35,
but some people have hyper mild at to
500 miles.
Hyper mild.
It would go on 45 miles an hour or
something.
Yeah,
like 30 miles an hour.
So it was like on level ground with a
pump the tires up really well and go on
a smooth surface and then you can go for
a long time.
But like definitely comfortably do 300
miles easier.
This is fine for most people.
Usually 200 or 250 miles is fine.
Three hundred miles is.
You don't even think about it really.
Is there any possibility that you could
use solar power solar powered one day?
Especially in Los Angeles.
I mean as you said about that giant
nuclear reactor a million times bigger
than earth.
Just floating in the sky.
Is it possible that one day you'll be
able to just power all these cars?
Just on solar power.
I mean we don't ever have cloudy days if
we do this,
three of them.
Well the surface area of a car is
without making the car like really
blocky or having some.
Like a g wagon?
Yeah.
Like,
and,
and just like having to look a lot of
surface area where like maybe like solar
panels fold out or something like your
class.
That's what we needed.
The type.
Yeah,
that the e a Jaguar e type with a giant
long hood.
That could be a giant solar panel.
What the beginning of the Tesla did want
to have this like unfolding solar panel
thing.
They'd press a button and it will just
unfold these solar panels.
I'm like,
charge,
recharge your car in the parking lot.
Ah Yeah,
we could do that,
but I think it's probably better to just
put that on your roof.
Right.
And then it's gonna be facing the sun
all the time because otherwise you're to
be in shade,
you know?
It could be in the shade,
a community garage or something like
that.
Yeah.
Didn't the fisker have that on the roof?
The fisker Karma.
New Generation for,
I believe it was only for the radio.
Is that correct?
Yeah,
I mean I think it could like reach out
like two miles a day or something.
Did you laugh when they started blowing
up?
When they get hit with water?
Do you remember what happened?
They got the what the,
when they had a dealership,
fisker Karma is we're parked.
Is that like that with a flood in
jersey?
When the hurricane came in,
they got overwhelmed with water and they
all started exploding.
Is fucking great video of it.
Did you watch the video?
Watch the video,
but I did see a picture of the actual
lubed up.
Watch that video.
Laugh my ass off.
They all blow up.
They got wet and they blew up.
That's not good.
Yeah.
We made out battery.
Waterproof,
so that doesn't happen.
Smart move.
Yeah.
There was a guy in Kazakhstan that I
think it was Kazakhstan,
that he.
He just bolted through a tunnel under an
underwater tunnel that could flooded
tunnel and just turn the wheels to steer
and pressed the accelerator and it just
floated through the tunnel and he
smiled,
steered around the other cars and you're
like,
that's amazing.
On the Internet.
What happens if your car gets a little
sideways?
Like if you're driving in snow,
like what if you're driving.
If you're autopilot is on and you're in
Denver and it snows out and your car
gets a little sideways,
does it correct itself?
It's got great traction control,
but doesn't know how to like.
Correct.
Do you know how like,
Oh yeah,
your ass and kicked out.
You know how to counter steer.
Oh yeah.
No,
that's really good.
He knows how to do it.
Yeah,
it's pretty crazy.
That's pretty crazy.
Yeah,
so like if you're going sideways,
he knows how to correct itself.
It generally won't go sideways.
It won't know why not.
It will correct itself before it goes
sideways.
Even in black guys.
Yeah.
You see this video is we see the car be
track alone.
Traction control system is very good.
It makes you feel like superman.
It's great.
You feel like you can make you feel like
there's incredible driver.
I believe it,
yeah.
Now how do you program what we do our
testing on like an lake in Sweden.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Norway and Canada and a few other
places.
Porsche does a lot of that too as well.
They do a lot of their.
They do some of their driver training
school on these frozen surfaces,
so you're just,
you.
The car is going sideways with you like
it or not,
and you have to learn how to slide into
corners and how do we test it?
Will electric cars have really great
traction control because the reaction
time is so fast.
So with a gasoline car,
you've got a lot of latency.
It takes awhile for the and the engine
to react and for you.
But for
electric motors,
incredibly precise.
That's why like,
like,
like if you had like a printer or
something,
uh,
you would only,
you wouldn't have a gasoline engine
printer.
That would be pretty weird.
Um,
or,
or like a surgical device.
It's going to be an electric motor on
the surgical device,
on the printer.
Gasoline engines going to be just
chugging away.
It's not going to have the reaction
time,
but to an electric motor,
it's operating at the second level so it
can turn on track,
on and off traction within inches of
getting on the honors.
Like let's say drive a patch of ice.
It'll turn traction off and then turn it
on a couple of inches right after the
ice,
like a little patch of ice.
Because in the frame of the electric
motor,
you're moving incredibly slowly.
You're like a snake.
It's your snail.
You're just moving so slowly because
it's,
it's it,
it can see at a thousand frames a second
and say one Mississippi.
It just thought about if things a
thousand times.
So it's realized that your wheels are
not getting traction.
It understand that there's some slippery
surface that you driving on.
Yes.
And it makes adjustments in real time.
And milliseconds.
That was,
that'd be so much safer than a regular
car.
Yes.
It is just that alone for loved ones.
You,
you,
you'd want them to be driving in your
car.
Yes.
The onboard fuck regular motors that the
s x and three art have the lowest
probability of injury of any cars ever
tested by the US government.
Well,
this is.
Yeah,
it's pretty fun.
It's pretty crazy.
Like wheat,
you know,
people still sue us,
like they'll have like some accident at
60 miles an hour where they'd like
twisted an ankle and they slip.
They like there'll be dead in another
car.
They still sue us.
But that's to be expected.
It is to be expected.
Do you take that into account with like
the same sort of fatalistic and you
know,
undertones to sort of just go,
uh,
you gotta just let it go.
This is what people do tell you.
I've got to,
but it is quite a lot of respect for the
justice system.
Judges are very smart and they see,
they,
like I've so far I've found judges to be
very good at justice because I like,
like what?
Like,
and juries are good too.
Like they're actually quite good,
you know,
people,
you read about like occasional errors
and the justice system,
let me tell you,
most of the time the very good,
um,
and the other guy mentioned that who
fell asleep in the car and you,
he wrote over a cyclist and you know,
and,
and that was what
encouraged me to get autopilot out as
soon as possible.
That guy sued us.
He sued you for Falling Asleep?
Yes.
He,
he,
I,
I'm not gonna he blamed it on the new
car smell.
Okay.
What?
Yes.
He blamed him falling asleep on your new
car smell.
There's someone who's annoying.
This is a real thing that happened was
there's a lawyer that thought that
through in front of his laptop before he
wrote that up.
Yes.
He got a lawyer and he sued us and the
judge was like,
you're crazy.
Stop bothering me.
No,
thank God.
Yes,
Thank God there's a judge out there with
a brain until you dredges are judges a
very good.
Some of them.
What about that?
Just a lot of boys up up the river in
Pennsylvania who was selling those kids
out.
You know about that story?
Judge was selling young boys to
presence.
He was like literally.
Yeah.
Literally under bribes for he was.
Was this an elected judge or.
I'd have a judge that's like actually a
politician elected judge.
This is a very famous story who he's in
jail right now I think for the rest of
his life,
and he put away.
He would take like a young boy would do
something like steal something from a
store and he would put them in detention
for five years,
something ridiculous,
egregious,
and they investigated this history and
they found out that he was literally
being paid off.
Was it by private prisons?
Is that what the deal was?
There was some sort of a.
But anyway,
this judges two judges who judges kids
for cash scandal is what called the
common pleas judges.
So I think they are elected.
And who was paying them?
Oh,
um,
someone.
It was proven to the point where they're
in jail now that someone was paying them
to put more asses in the seats in these
private prisons,
million dollar payment to put them in
the youth centers builder.
A million dollar payment.
Yeah.
I do think it's this private prisons
thing is creating a bad incentive.
Dark,
right?
Yes.
But that judge is in prison.
Thank God.
Yes.
But for people who think perhaps the
justice system consists entirely of
judges like that.
I want to assure you this is not the
case.
The vast majority of judges have very
good.
I agree.
And they care about justice and they
could have made a lot more money if they
wanted to be a trial lawyer and instead
they cared about justice and they made
less money because they care about
justice.
And that's why they're judges.
I feel that same way about police
officers.
I feel like there's so many interactions
with so many different people with
police officers that the very few that
stand out that are horrific,
we tend to look at that like this is
evidence that police are all corrupt and
not.
I think that's crazy.
No,
most,
most police are,
are,
are very honest.
Um,
and uh,
and,
and like the military or military
personnel
that I know of very honorable ethical
people and much more honorable ethical
than the average person.
That's my impression.
That's my impression as well.
But that's not to suggest that we be
complacent and assume everyone's honest
and ethical.
And obviously if somebody is,
is given ape,
a trusted place in society such as being
a police officer or a judge and they all
corrupt,
then we must be extra vigilant against
such situations and take action.
Uh,
but,
but we should not think that this is
somehow broadly descriptive of people in
that profession.
I couldn't agree more.
I think there's also an issue with,
um,
one of the things that happens with
police officers,
prosecutors,
and,
and anyone that's trying to convict
someone or arrest someone is that it
becomes a game and in games people want
to win.
Sometimes people cheat.
Yes,
yes.
I mean,
if,
you know,
if your prosecutor shoot,
you should not always went to when they
are times when you should,
like,
okay,
I just did not want to win this case.
Um,
and then just pass on that case.
Sometimes people want to win too much.
That is true.
Um,
I think also the,
they call it becomes tough if you're,
if you're like a district Tony,
you know,
you tend to sort of see a lot of
criminals and then your view of the
world can get negatively,
you know,
have a negative,
you have a negative view of the world
because,
you know,
you're just interacting with a lot of
criminals.
But actually most of society is not
consistent criminals.
Um,
and we had this conversation with Dennis
several years ago with Tony.
I was like,
man,
I must sometimes seem pretty,
pretty dark because,
you know,
man,
there's some,
some terrible human beings out there.
And he was like,
Yep.
And he was like dealing with some case
which consisted of a couple of old
ladies that would run people over
somehow for insurance money.
It was rough.
I was like,
wow,
that's pretty rough as like,
it's like hard to maintain faith in
humanity if you're a district attorney,
but,
but you know,
it's only a few percent of society that
are actually bad.
And then if you go to the worst say
point one percent of society or the
worst one in a thousand one in a
million,
you know,
like how bad is the millionth worst
person in the United States?
Pretty damn bad.
Like damn evil.
Like the,
the million,
like the millionth of one in a million
of evil is so evil.
He will,
could not even conceive of it.
But there's 330 million people in the
United States.
So that's 330 people out there
somewhere.
But by the same token,
there's also 330 people are incredible
angels and unbelievably good human
beings.
Yeah,
on the other side.
But because of our fear of danger,
we tend to.
Our thoughts tend to gravitate towards
the worst case scenario and we want to
frame that and that is one of the real
problems with prejudice.
We want,
whether it's prejudice towards a
different minorities or prejudice
towards police officers or anything.
So we want to look at the worst case
scenario and say this is an example of
what this is all about.
And you see that even with people,
how they frame genders and some some men
from women like that,
they get ripped off by a few women and
they said all women are evil.
Some women get fucked over by a few men.
All men are shit.
And in this this is very toxic and it's
also,
it's a very unbalanced way of viewing
the world and it's very emotionally
based and it's based on your own
experience,
your own anecdotal experience.
And it can.
It can be very influential to the people
around you.
And it's just.
It's a dangerous way.
It's a dangerous thought process and
pattern to promote.
It is.
It is a very dangerous pattern.
I really think people should give other
people the benefit of the doubt and
assume that they're good until proven
otherwise,
and I think really most people are
actually pretty good people.
Nobody's perfect.
You have to be.
If you think of vast numbers of us,
they're just interacting with each
other,
with each other constantly.
We have to be better than we think we
are.
There's no other way right here.
All these weapons.
But how many times,
like nobody's presumably tried to murder
you in your industry.
Yes.
Nobody is like fake flame thrower here.
Not a flame thrower.
Now we've got a real problem.
I'm going to put it on that side too.
I'm going to leave it for the guests.
Yeah.
I'm like,
look man,
if I say something that fucked up,
it's right there.
So to liven things up for sure.
Guaranteed to make any party better.
Yeah.
Well that's.
I mean that's the armed a civilization
theory,
right?
That an armed community is a safe and
polite community
in Texas.
It's kind of true.
Yeah.
I mean,
people in Texas are super polite and
everybody don't make somebody angry.
Don't know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
It's not a good mood.
Piss people off when everybody can have
a gun.
Just let that guy get in your lane.
Yeah.
We've got a big,
a test site in central Texas near Waco.
Beautiful space x,
uh,
in Mcgregor just about 15 minutes away
from Waco.
It's close to where Ted nugent lives.
It has to Ted nugent.
Okay,
cool.
Yeah,
there are,
you know,
we have lots of fire,
loud explosions and things and people
like that.
They're cool with it.
They don't give a fuck out there.
They're very supportive.
You can buy fireworks where your kids go
to school.
Yeah.
It's,
you know,
it's dangerous.
Yeah.
But it's free.
It's free.
This is something that's very enticing
because of that.
It is dangerous,
but it's also free,
right?
Yeah.
I kinda like Texas.
Well,
I prefer it over places that are more
restrictive but more liberal because you
could always be liberal like just
because things are free and just because
you have a certain amount of,
you know,
right wing type characters,
it doesn't mean you have to be that way,
you know,
and honestly there's a lot of those
people that are pretty fucking open
minded and let you do whatever you want
to do and you don't bother them.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's my hope right now with the way
we're able to communicate with each
other today and how radically different
it is than generations past is that we
all just.
The dust settles and we all realized
like,
like what you were saying,
that most people are good.
Most people are good.
The vast majority.
Yes.
I think you should give people the
benefit of the doubt for sure.
I think you're right.
Yeah.
You know what can help that?
What mushrooms do.
Anything.
They're delicious.
Yeah.
Right there.
Good for you.
To all of them,
all kinds of.
What do you see in terms of when you
think about the future of your
companies,
what do you see as like bottlenecks?
He wants more of this.
Sure.
Thank you.
What do you see in terms of like
bottlenecks of things that are,
that are holding back innovation?
Is it regulatory commissions and people
that don't understand the technology
that are influencing policy?
Like what?
What?
What could potentially be holding you
guys back?
Right.
No.
Is there anything that you would change?
Yeah,
that's a good question.
You know,
I wish.
I wish politicians were better at
science.
That would help a lot.
That's a problem.
Yes.
There's no incentive for them to be good
at science.
There isn't.
I'm actually,
you know,
they're,
they're pretty good at science in China,
I have to say.
Yeah.
The mayor of Beijing is,
I believe in environmental engineering
degree and the deputy mayor as a physics
degree.
I met them and the mayor say,
Shanghai has really smart and you're up
on technology.
What do you think about this government
policy of,
of stopping use of walway phones and
there's something about the,
the,
the worry about spying is,
I mean,
from what I've understand from real tech
people,
they think it's horseshit.
Oh,
I don't know.
I'm like the government said don't you,
by Huawei phones.
Is that do,
are you up on that are all now,
should we just spend in this idea?
And I think like I guess if you're,
if you're,
uh,
if you have like top secret stuff,
um,
then you want to be pretty careful about
what hardware you use.
Uh,
but you know,
like most people do not have top secret
stuff and like nobody cares what porn
you watch,
you know,
it's like nobody actually cares,
you know?
So if they do,
that's kind of on them.
Like national spy agencies do not,
do not give a rat's ass watch porn.
You Watch,
they do not to care.
So like what secrets does a national spy
agency have to learn from the average
citizen?
Probably nothing.
Well,
that's the argument against the,
the,
the narrative in the argument by a lot
of these tech people is that the real
concern is that these companies like
Huawei are innovating at a radical pace
and they're trying to stop them from
integrating into our culture and letting
this.
Right.
Right now,
they're the number two cell phone
manufacturer in the world.
Okay.
Samsung's number one hallway is number
two apples.
Now,
number three,
they surpassed apple is number two.
And the idea is that this is all taking
place without them having any foothold
whatsoever.
In America there are no,
there's no carriers that have their
phones.
You have to buy their phones unlocked
through some sort of a third party and
then put.
Okay.
So the worry is that these are somehow
or another controlled by the Chinese
government.
The communist Chinese government is
going to distribute these phones and I
don't know if it's the worries,
economic influence that they'll have too
much power.
I don't know what it is.
Are you,
are you paying attention on any of this?
Not really,
no.
I don't think we worry too much about
Huawei phones.
Uh,
you know,
maybe you know,
our national security agencies shouldn't
have how?
Well,
maybe that's a question mark,
but I think for the average citizen,
doesn't matter just like.
No,
I'm pretty sure the Chinese government
does not care about the goings on of the
average American citizen is.
Is there a time where you think that
there will be no security will be
impossible to hold back information that
whatever bottleneck will,
will let go.
We're gonna,
we're gonna give in that whatever
bottleneck between privacy and ultimate
innovation will,
will have to be bridged in order for us
to achieve the next level of
technological proficiency.
That we're just going to abandon it and
there'll be no,
no security,
no privacy.
Do people want privacy because they seem
to put everything on the Internet?
Well,
right now they're confused,
but when you're talking about your neuro
link and this,
this idea that one day we're going to be
able to share information and we're
going to be some sort of a thing that
symbiotically create a symbiotic and
connected.
I think we really need to worry about
security and that situation and one.
Sure.
That's like a security repair amount.
Sure,
but also we will,
we will be is will be so much different.
Lark,
our concerns about money,
about status,
about where all these things will will
seemingly go by the wayside if we really
become enlightened,
if we really become artificially
enlightened by some sort of an ai
interface where we have this symbiotic
relationship with some new Internet type
connection to inflammation.
What?
What happens then?
What is important?
What is not important?
Is Privacy important when we're all
gods?
I mean I think the things that we think
are important,
key private right now we probably will
not think are important.
Right.
Information,
right?
What do you,
what do you hide?
Emotions.
What do we hide?
I mean,
I think like,
I don't know,
maybe it's like embarrassing,
so embarrassing stuff,
but
there's actually like I think people,
there's not that much that's kept
private.
The people that is actually relevant,
right?
That's people what other people would
actually care about and we think other
people care about it,
but they don't really care about her
sense.
Certainly governments don't.
Yeah,
well some people care about it,
but then it gets weird when you,
when it gets exposed,
like Jennifer Lawrence when I was naked,
pictures of her God exposed like I think
in some ways people liked her more than
they realize like,
oh,
she's just a person that just a girl who
likes sacs and it's just alive and has a
boyfriend and send them messages and now
you get to look into it and you probably
shouldn't have somebody let it go and
they put it online and the all right.
She seems to be done.
Okay.
Person.
She's just you and me and the same
thing.
She just send some weird place where
she's on a 35 foot tall screen with
music playing every time she talks.
Yeah,
I,
I'm sure she's,
she's not,
uh,
not happy about it but she,
she's.
But she's clearly doing fine.
But once this interface is fully
realized where we really do become
something far more powerful in terms of
our cognitive ability,
our ability to understand irrational
thoughts and mitigate them and that
we're all connected and some sort of an
insane way.
What I mean,
how,
what,
uh,
what are thoughts on wealth,
our thoughts on social status,
like how many of those just evaporate
and our need for privacy.
Maybe our need for privacy will be the
ultimate bottleneck that we'll have to
subsidize that we'll have to surpass.
I think
the things that we think are important.
No will probably not to be important in
the future,
but there will be things that are
important for things.
I don't know.
They might be some war of ideas
potentially.
I don't think Darwin's going away.
Right?
No one's going to be there.
That was on will be there forever.
Forever.
Yeah.
It would just be a difference in a
different arena.
Different.
The
digital arena,
different arena.
Dawn is not going away.
What keeps you up at night?
Well,
it's quite hard to run companies.
Yeah.
Especially car companies.
How did they.
It's quite challenging.
The car businesses,
the hardest one of all the things you
do.
Yes,
because it's a consumer oriented
business as opposed to like space x and
not that space x space X.
There's no walk in the park but,
but a car company,
it's very difficult to keep a company
alive.
It's very difficult.
You know,
there's only two car companies and the
history of American car companies that
haven't gone bankrupt.
And that's Ford and Tesla.
That's it.
Yeah.
Ford wrote out that crazy storm.
Huh?
They're the only ones.
The skin of their teeth shout out to the
Mustang.
Yeah.
By the skin of their teeth.
That is interesting.
Right?
Same with Tesla.
We barely survived.
How close did you get to folding?
Very close.
We a 2008 is not a good time to be a car
company,
especially a startup company and
especially in electric car company.
I was like stupidity squared and this is
when you had those cool roadsters with
the t top with the.
I'm a target top.
Yeah.
We had like a,
he was a highly modified elise chassis.
The body was all completely different,
but that was super dumb strategy that we
actually did was dumb.
It was based on false premises.
One false premise was that we'd be able
to,
uh,
cheaply convert the Lotus Elise and use
that as a core platform and that we will
be able to use technology from this
little company called ace propulsion for
the electric drive train.
And the battery problem is they
propulsion technology to not work in
production and we ended up using none of
it in long term.
None of it.
We have to redesign everything.
And then the,
once you add a battery pack and electric
motor to the cart,
got a heavier cut,
30 percent heavier,
invalidated the entire structure,
all the crash structure,
everything had to be redone,
nothing like that.
I think it had less than seven percent
of the parts were common with any other
device including cars or anything else?
The seven percent yes.
Everything including tires and wheels,
bolts breaks even every year.
And we'll see the steering wheel was.
I think the steering wheel was almost
the same.
Yes.
The windscreen went Wednesday.
No,
I think the windscreen is the same.
Yes,
I think.
I think we were able to keep the last
seven percent.
So that's basically every body panel was
different.
The entire structure was different.
The way we couldn't use the H,
like the
HVAC system,
the view of the air conditioner was belt
driven,
air conditioner off.
So now we needed a something that was
electrically driven which needed a new
AC compressor and all that takes away
from the battery life as well.
Right?
Yeah.
We needed an small,
highly efficient air conditioning system
that fit in a tiny car and was
electrically powered belt driven.
It's very difficult.
How much do those weigh those cars?
The roadster,
I think it was about 2,700
pounds.
That's still very depending on which
version?
Twenty six,
52,
27,
50 pounds,
something like that.
And what was the weight distribution?
It was about 50.
Well they were different versions of the
car.
So it's about 55 on the rear because
we're bias.
Right.
But not bad considering like a nine
slash 11,
which is like one of the most popular
sports cards of all time heavy.
We're in bias.
Well,
I mean yeah,
the nine slash 11.
Like the joke is like the bench dirt,
despite Newton not being on their side.
If you have fighting Newton,
it's very difficult.
Well,
it's like if you've got this,
the moments of inertia on nine slash 11
don't make any sense.
They do.
Once you understand them,
once you understood,
don't want to hang the engine off the
ass.
This is not a wise move.
You don't want to let up on the gas.
When you're in a corner,
you,
the problem with,
uh,
with,
with something,
that's where the engine is mounted over
the rear axle or off the rear axle,
towards the rear is that you pull them
moment of inertia is fundamentally
screwed.
You cannot solve this.
It's unsolvable.
You're screwed.
Pull them over to know Sherry.
You're screwed,
right?
Like,
seriously.
If you spun the car like a top,
that that's your polar moment of
inertia.
You're just,
I promised,
I wouldn't swear to this show by the
way,
really to who it was a friend.
Tell that friend to go fuck himself.
Who told you not to swear.
Read a good friend.
You realize you're fucking Elan Musk can
do whatever you want,
man.
If you ever get confused,
call me elsewhere and private.
Swear up a storm.
Just say fricking fun way.
There's like old house moms that have
children.
That's fricking thing.
Yeah.
But anyway,
like the Porsche,
it's kind of incredible how well Porsche
handles given that it's the physics,
the moments of inertia.
So messed up,
uh,
to actually still make it work well is,
is incredible.
Well,
if you know how to turn into the corner
and once you get used to the feeling of
it,
there's actual benefits to it.
You know,
there,
there are some benefits.
I enjoy the car I had before.
Tesla was a nine slash seven.
Oh,
nine,
seven or six or seven.
Yeah.
I'm great car man.
I mean particularly with other Porsche
stutter when they had the variable veins
a turbo and yet don't have the turbo
lag.
That was great.
Yeah,
that was really great.
The turbo lag was like,
you know,
your floor it,
like photo home,
call your mom the older one,
but an hour later the car accelerates.
Super dangerous too because in the real
world starts spinning.
Yeah.
There's something fun about it though,
like feeling that rear weight kicking
around,
you know,
and again I could feel to it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I agree.
But that's what I was talking about
earlier about that
card that I have 93,
nine slash 11.
It's just there's not fast.
It's not,
it's not the best handling car but it's
more satisfying than any other car I
have because it's so mechanical.
It's like everything about it like crack
holes and bumps and it gives you all
this feedback and I take it to the
comedy store because when I get there I
feel like my brain is just pop in and
it's on fire.
It's like a strategy for me now that I
really stopped driving other cars there.
I drive that car there just for the
brain juice.
Just for the owner.
The interaction.
I mean you should try model s p 100 d
will blow your mind your skull.
Okay.
Yeah.
Tell me what to order.
I'll order one LSP,
100 d.
okay.
Jamie,
that's the Tesla car that I drive.
Okay.
Okay,
I'll get with the car you drive.
Okay.
It will blow your mind out of your
spirit.
I believe you.
How can I drive 300 miles?
That's good for la.
Regular days.
You'll never notice the battery.
Never,
never.
How hard is it to get like one of them
crazy plugs installed in your house?
That difficult?
Now it's super easy.
It's like,
yeah,
it's like a dryer plug.
It's like a dryer outlet.
Didn't you come up with some crazy tiles
for your roof that are solar paneled?
Yeah,
yeah,
we're have it on my roof right now.
Actually,
I'm just trying it out.
But it's like,
it's the thing is it takes while to like
test roof stuff because roofs have to
last a long time.
So like your watch your roof to last
like 30 years for a regular groove now.
So there's two versions.
There's like the solar panels you put on
a roof.
So like depends on whether your roofs
new or old.
So if you're roof new you don't want to
replace the roof,
you want to put solar panels on the
roof.
Um,
so that's like retrofit,
you know,
and they were trying to make the
retrofit Pendleton Grill Nice.
Um,
and then,
but then the new product we're coming
out with is if you,
if you have a roof that's either you're
building a house or you're going to
replace your roof anyway,
then you make the site,
the tiles have solar,
solar cells embedded in the tiles and
then it's quite a tricky thing because
you want to not see the solar cell
behind the glass tile.
Uh,
so you have to really work with the
glass and,
and,
and the,
and the various coatings and layers so
that you don't see the solar cell behind
the glass,
otherwise it doesn't look right.
Right.
So it's really tricky.
There's this shame and put it up there.
Yeah,
that looks good.
See,
like if you look closely,
you can see if you're zooming in,
right?
You can see the,
you can see the cell,
but if you zoom out you don't see the
sale.
Right.
Well it looks cool though.
That's hard.
It's really hard because you have to
have sunlight go through.
Right.
But when it gets reflected back out,
it doesn't,
it,
it hides the fact that there's a sale
there.
Now.
Are those available to the consumer
right now?
Well,
we have a,
I think those on that roof right there.
Yes.
That's amazing.
Oh,
that looks good.
Yeah.
Ooh,
I liked that one too.
Smart.
Oh,
so you get that kind of fake Spanish
looking thing.
I like French late.
That's why people in Connecticut smoking
pipes will get that one.
Yeah.
That's bad ass dude.
So those will actually work,
I believe you.
So the,
the,
the solar panels that are on that house
that we just looked at,
is that sufficient to power the entire
home?
It depends on your energy on how.
Yeah.
So,
um,
generally yes.
I would say it's probably for most it's
going to vary,
but anywhere from more than you need to
maybe half,
like half to one point.
Five of the energy that you need
depending on how much roof you have
relative to living space and how
ridiculous you are with the TV.
TV is no problem.
Air Conditioning,
air conditioning,
air conditioning is the problem.
If you have an efficient air conditioner
and you don't,
and depending on how like are you at
conditioning rooms when they don't need
to be air conditioned,
which is very common because it's a pain
in the neck and it was like programming
or BCR.
It's like right now it's just blinking
12.
I'll tell people just like to hell with
that.
I'm just gonna make it this temperature
all day long.
Don't have a smart home where if you're
in the room then it stays cool.
Right?
Yeah.
It should predict when you're going to
be home and then cool.
The room,
the rooms that you're likely to use with
a little bit of intelligence.
We're not talking about like genius home
here.
We're just talking like elementary basic
stuff.
You know,
like if you could hook that into the
car,
like knows you're coming home.
Like there's no point in calling the
home,
keeping the,
keeping the home really cool when you're
not there,
but I can tell that you're coming home.
What's going to cool it to the right
temperature,
right.
We have an editor that works with your
solar panels or anything like that.
Yeah,
yeah,
we do and we need to hook it into the
air conditioning to.
I really make the air conditioning work.
Have you thought about creating an air
conditioning system?
I know you have a trick question.
I cannot answer questions about ritual
potential.
Let's just let it go.
We'll move on to the next thing,
but that would be an interesting idea.
Yeah,
I would say radiant heating,
all that
good ideas.
Now when you,
when you think about the efficiency of
these homes and you think about
implementing solar power and battery
power and is there anything else that
people are missing?
Is there any other.
Like I just saw a smartwatch that is
powered by the heat of the human body.
Some new technology is able to fully
power that way.
I don't know if it's fully or if it's
like this watch right here.
This is a casio,
it's called a pro tech and it's in like
an outdoors watch and solar powered and
so it has the ability to operate for a
certain amount of time on solar.
So if you have it exposed,
it could function for a certain amount
of time on solar.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
I'm like,
there's this health lighting watches
where it's just got to wait in the watch
and as you move your wrist,
the weight moves from one side to the
other and it winds the watch up.
That's a pretty cool thing.
Yeah.
It's amazing that Rolex is that it's all
done mechanically.
There's no batteries in there and it's
no nothing.
Yeah,
you could do the same thing.
Create a little charger that's based on
a risk movement.
It really depends on how much energy or
what she uses.
You know,
what's fucked up about that though.
We accept a certain amount of like
fuckery with those watches.
Like I brought my watch,
I have a rolex that uh,
my friend Lorenzo gave me and I brought
it to the watch store and I said,
this thing's always fast.
I said,
it's always like after a couple months
it's like five minutes fast and they go,
Yep,
bigly.
Yeah.
It's just what it does.
Okay,
well hold on.
I go.
So you telling me that it just is always
going to be fast.
They just like,
yeah.
It's just like every few months you
gotta reset.
It seems like they should recalibrate
that thing.
They can't.
They tried.
They see every few months with it's four
months or five months or six months.
It's going to be a couple minutes fast.
Okay.
It seems like they should really
recalibrate that because if it's always
fast you can just delete those minutes.
You need to fucking kicked down the door
at Rolex and go,
you bitches are lazy.
It's kind of amazing that you can keep
time mechanically on a wristwatch with
these tiny little gears.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
I mean the whole luxury watch market is
fascinating.
I,
I'm,
I'm not that involved in,
in terms of like I don't buy them.
I bought them as gifts so I don't buy
them for myself,
but when I look at them online,
if there's million dollar watches out
there now that are like,
they have like little rotating moons and
stars and they live like,
look at this thing.
How much does that one,
Jamie [inaudible] preposterous.
I like gears.
I just love them and it looked
beautiful,
but there's some of these people that
are just taking it right in the ass.
They buying these watches for like
$750,000.
I'm like,
Yo,
that's a timex son.
Nobody knows.
It's not any better than some cassio
that you could just buy online.
Like,
look at that though.
Well,
here's the thing.
If you're a person that doesn't,
just want to know the time you want
craftsmanship,
you want some artisans touch.
You want innovation in terms of like a
person figuring out how gears and cogs
all line up perfectly to every time it
turns over,
it's basically a second.
I mean that's just.
There's art to that.
It's not just telling time,
hey,
I like this watch a lot,
but if it got hit by a rock,
I wouldn't be sad.
It's just a watch.
It's a mass produced thing that runs on
some courts battery,
but those things that's.
There's art to that.
No,
I agree.
It's beautiful.
Yeah.
Love it.
There's something.
There's something amazing about it.
It's a.
because it represents the human
creativity.
It's not just.
It's not just a electronic innovation.
There's something.
There's a person's work in that.
Yes,
but you don't have a watch on.
No,
ever.
I used to have a watch.
What happened?
My phone tells the time point,
but if you lose your phone,
do you wait?
Hold on,
let me guess.
You are a no case guy.
That's correct.
On the edge.
Grasse Tyson,
neela grass titus who was in here last
week.
I'm marveled at his ability to get
through life without a case.
That's right.
You know,
he takes his phone and he flips it in
between his fingers like,
like a,
like a.
A soldier would do it.
His rifle or his roles that shed in
between his fingers.
Okay.
Marvelous.
Wow.
He says that's the reason why they do
it.
He said,
when you look at someone who has a
rifle,
why would they do that?
Why would they flip it around like that?
Right.
So that when it goes to drop,
they have it in their hand,
they catch it quickly.
So that's what he does with his phone.
He's just flipping his phone around all
the time.
I got that in Mexico.
I was hoping it holds joint,
doesn't do anything.
It seems to open it just as a host,
a whole storage store,
things in there,
but like try to put a joint in there and
close it.
You put like one,
one blunt one,
but it seems pretentious,
you know,
that's the idea behind it.
I bought it when I was in Mexico because
I figured it'd be a good size to hold
joints or
so.
Is that a joint or is it a cigar?
You know,
it's um,
marijuana inside of a tobacco.
Oh,
okay.
So it's like plot plot tobacco never had
that.
Yeah,
I think I tried one once.
Come on,
man,
probably can't because stockholders,
right?
I mean,
it's legal,
right?
It's totally legal.
Okay.
How does it work?
Do People get upset at you if you do
certain things?
A backhoe and marijuana in there,
that's all
it is.
Did the combination of tobacco and
marijuana is wonderful?
First turned onto it by Charlie Murphy
and then reignited by Dave Chappelle
plus whiskey.
Exactly.
Perfect.
Balances it out.
Alcohol is a drug that's been
grandfathered in.
Well,
it's not just.
It's a drug that gets a bad rap because
you could just have a little.
It's great.
Fine.
Yeah.
A little sip here and there and just
your inhibitions are relaxed and it
shows your true self and hopefully
you're more joyous and friendly and
happy and everything's good.
The real worry is that people that can't
handle it,
like the real worried about people who
can handle cars that can go zero to 60
in one point nine seconds or anything.
Have you ever considered something that
like imagine if one day everyone has a
car that's on the same,
at least technological standard is one
of your cars and everyone agrees that
the smart thing to do is not just to
have bumpers,
but to perhaps have some sort of a
magnetic repellent device,
something,
some electro magnetic field around the
cars.
As cars come close to each other,
they automatically radically decelerate
because of magnets or something.
Well,
I mean our cars brake automatically
break.
Yeah.
When they see things,
yes,
but look a physical barrier like a.
well,
the wheels work pretty well.
We'll know pretty well decelerated at
one point,
one to one point two g's,
that kind of thing.
Is there a concern that one day all your
cars will be on the road and there
they'll still be regular people with
regular cars 20,
30 years from now that'll get in the mix
and be the the main problem?
Yeah.
I think it was sort of like know it was
a time of transition where there were
horses and gasoline cars in the road at
the same time.
It's been pretty weird.
Oh,
that would be the weirdest.
Yeah.
Horses were tricky.
You don't want to be back in a Manhattan
had like 300,000
horses.
You figure like horse lives.
Fifteen years.
Got 20,000
horses that Robin Dad every day or every
year I should say every year.
20,000
horses.
If this 300,000
horses in 15 year lifespan back in the
gangs in New York days.
That movie.
Yeah.
It's a lot of dead horses now.
You need a dead horse to move the horse.
Right?
The probably get pretty freaked out if
they have to a dead horse because they
know what's going on.
Yeah,
I mean it's pretty weird.
No,
I would imagine dragon this dead horse
around and I'm a horse.
Do you ever stop,
stop
and think about your role in.
Do you ever stop and think about your
role in the culture?
Because me as a person who never met you
until today,
when I think of you,
you know,
I've always thought of you as being this
weirdo super inventor dude who just
somehow or another keeps coming up with
new shit,
but there's not a lot of you out there
like everybody else seems to be.
I mean obviously you make a lot of money
and there's a lot of people that make a
lot of money.
Like that clock.
Yeah.
Pretty Dope.
Right?
This is a great clock.
Yeah.
You want one?
I'll get you one.
Sure.
Okay.
Done.
I like weird things like this.
Oh,
this is the coolest.
Is tgt promotion.
What is his tgt studios?
Tgt Studios.
Yeah.
To a gentleman who makes all this by
hand.
Yeah.
It's really cool.
With study is filled with where devices.
Well,
get ready for another one.
All right.
I'm sending it your way.
Well,
you want to Werewolf to hook you up.
All right.
I'll take one.
One a werewolf and 1:00
coming up.
Do you think about your role in the
culture?
Because me as a person,
they ever met you until today.
I've always looked at you and like,
wow,
like how's this guy just keep inventing
shit.
Like how do you,
how do you keep coming up with all these
new devices and what do you ever
consider how anew?
Like I had a dream once that there was a
million tesla's instead of like one
tesla,
there was a million.
Tesla's not Chesley the car,
but Nicola.
Oh yeah,
sure.
And that in his day there was a million
people like him who were radically
innovative.
It was a weird dream,
man.
It was so strange and I've had it more
once the results in a very rapid
technology innovation,
that's for sure.
It's one of the only dreams in my life.
I've had more than one time.
Okay.
Like where I've woken up and it's in the
same dream,
I'm in the same dream and in this dream
it's 19 forties,
19 fifties,
but everyone is severely advanced.
There's flying blimps with lcd screens
on the side of them and everything is
bizarre and strange and it stuck with me
for whatever it.
Obviously this is just a stupid dream,
but for whatever reason,
all these years that stuck with me like
it takes one man,
like Nikola Tesla to have more than a
hundred inventions that were patents.
Right?
I mean he had some pretty great,
pretty fucking amazing ideas.
Yes.
But there was in his day there was very
few people like him because it's true.
What if there was a million,
like what exists advance very quickly.
Right.
But there's not a million.
Elon Musk's is one motherfucker.
Do you have think about that?
We just try to not.
Hm.
I don't think.
I don't think you'd necessarily want to
be me.
I.
Well,
what's the worst part about it?
If people would like it that much,
well most people wouldn't,
but they can't be you.
So that's like,
that's like some superhero type Shit,
you know?
He wouldn't want to be spiderman rather
this sleep tight and Gotham city.
I hope he's out there doing his job.
It's very hard to turn it off.
Yeah.
What's the hardest part?
Might sound great to me,
but what if it doesn't turn off?
Now I showed you the isolation tank and
you've never experienced that before.
I think that could help you turn it off
a little bit just for the night.
Yeah,
just give you a little bit of sleep.
A little bit of perspective is magnesium
that you get from the water as well.
That makes you,
makes you sleep easier because the water
has epsom salts in it,
but maybe some sort of strategy for
sacrificing your,
a biologic or not sacrificing but
enhancing your biological recovery time
by figuring out a way,
whether it's through meditation or some
other ways to shut off that.
That thing at night.
Like you must have like a constant
stream of ideas.
It's running through your head all the
time.
Getting text messages from checks.
No.
Uh,
I,
I'm getting text messages from friends
saying,
what the hell are you doing?
Smoking weed?
Is that bad for you?
It's legal.
It's got to be an approved.
It's not,
you know,
uh,
I'm not a regular smoker of weed.
How often you smoke it?
Almost never.
Mm.
I mean it's,
it's,
I don't actually notice any effect.
Well,
there you go.
There was a time where,
I think it was ram das or someone gave
some Buddhist monk bunch acid.
Okay.
And he ate it and it had no effect on
them.
I doubt that I would say that too,
but I've never meditated to the level
that some of these people that were
there constantly meditating all day,
they don't have any material possessions
and all of their energy is spent trying
to achieve a certain mindset.
I would like to cynically deny that.
I'd like to cynically say contagious
fucking think the same way I do.
They just hang out with flip flops on
and make weird noises,
but maybe now you know,
I,
I know a lot of people like reed and
that's fine,
but I don't find that it is very good to
full productivity for you,
but for me,
yeah,
it's definitely.
I would imagine that for someone like
you,
it's not someone like you,
it,
it'd be more like a cup coffee.
Right?
You want your latte?
Yeah.
That's more like the opposite of a cup
of coffee,
a cup of coffee and reverse.
Oh,
weed is.
No.
I'm saying you would like more,
more like,
will it be beneficial to you?
It'd be like coffee.
I like to get things done.
I like to be useful.
Um,
that is one of the hardest things to do
is to be useful.
When you say you like to get things done
in terms of like what you get to
satisfaction when you complete a
project,
when something,
something that you invent comes to
fruition and you see people enjoying it.
That feeling yes.
Doing something useful for other people
that I liked doing.
That's interesting for other people.
Yes.
So that.
Do you think that that is maybe the way
you recognize that you have this unusual
position in the culture where you can
uniquely influence certain things
because of this?
I mean you essentially have a gift,
right?
I mean you would think it was a curse,
but I'm sure it's been fueled by many,
many years of discipline and,
and learning,
but you essentially have a gift and that
you have this
radical sort of creativity engine when
it comes to innovation and technology.
It's like you're just,
you're going at a very high rpm all the
time.
What does that last and stuff?
I don't know what would've happened if I
got into a sensory deprivation tank.
Let's try.
It sounds concerning like running the
engine with no resistance.
That.
Is that what it is though?
Maybe it's not.
Maybe it's fine.
I don't know how I'll try it.
I'll try it.
Have you ever experimented with
meditation or anything?
Yes.
What do you do or what have you done
rather?
I mean you just sort of sit there and
required and then repeat some mantra
which acts as a focal point.
It's still the mind.
It just stolen mind,
but I don't find myself drawn to it
frequently.
Do you think that perhaps productivity
is maybe more attractive to you then
enlightenment and or even the concept of
whatever enlightenment means.
Like what are you trying to achieve when
you're meditating all the time?
What would you.
It seems like almost like there's a
frantic ness to your creativity that
comes out of this,
this burning furnace,
and in order for you to like calm that
thing down,
he got thrown.
Might have to throw it too much water on
it.
It's like a never ending explosion.
Like what is it like I try and explain
it to a dumb person like me.
What's going on at her and never under
any explosion.
It's just constant ideas.
Just bouncing around.
Yes.
Ooh Damn.
Yeah,
so when everybody leaves,
just Elan sitting at home,
brushing his teeth.
Just of ideas bouncing around your head
the whole time.
When did you realize that that's not the
case with most people?
I think when I was,
I don't know,
five or six or something,
I thought I was insane.
Why do you think you're insane?
Because it was clear that other people
did not.
What?
Their mind wasn't exploding with ideas
all the time.
They were an expressing it.
They weren't talking about it all day
and you realize by the time you were
five or six,
like,
oh,
they're probably not even getting this
thing that I'm getting.
No,
it was just strange.
It was like,
hmm,
that's strange.
That was my conclusion.
I asked range,
but did you feel diminished by it in any
way?
Like knowing that this is a weird thing
that you really probably couldn't
commiserate with with other people,
they wouldn't understand that you hope
they wouldn't find out because they
might put me away with something.
You thought that for a second.
Yes.
When you were little and the other
people are wearing.
Or what if they put money away?
Like when you were little,
you thought this,
wow.
Like you thought this is so radically
different than the people that are
around me.
If they find out I got the stream coming
in.
Yeah.
Wow.
But,
you know,
I was only like five or six really.
Like,
do you think this is like.
I mean there's,
there's outliers biologically.
You mean there's people that are seven
foot nine.
There's people that have giant hands is
people that have eyes that are 20 slash
15 vision.
There's always outliers.
Um,
do you feel like you're caught this?
Like you have got some,
you're like on some weird innovation,
creativity sort of wave.
That's very unusual.
Like you tapped into.
I mean,
just think of the,
the,
the various things you've been able to
accomplish in a very short amount of
time and you're constantly doing this.
That's a weird.
You're weird person,
right?
I agree.
Yeah.
Like what if there's a million Elon
Musk's?
Well that would be very weird.
Woo.
Yeah,
that'd be pretty weird.
Like,
are real weird.
Definitely.
Yeah.
What if they're a million show rockets?
The probably is probably too many and I
mean,
I think that's the case with a lot of
folks.
Yeah.
I mean,
but like,
uh,
you know,
my goal is like try to useful things,
try to maximize it.
Probably the is good.
Um,
make the future exciting when you look
forward to,
you know,
know with,
uh,
you know,
with Tesla or like try and make things
that people love you.
I was like,
not like kit.
How are you?
How many things can you buy that you
really love,
that really give you joy?
So rare,
so rare.
I wish there were more things.
That's what we're trying to make things
that somebody loves.
When you,
when you think about making someone
loves,
like,
do you specifically think about like
what things would improve people's
experience?
Like what,
what would change the way people
interface with life that would make them
more relaxed or more happy?
You really think like when you thinking
about things like that,
is that one of your considerations?
Like what?
What can I do that would help people
that maybe they wouldn't be able to
figure it out?
Yeah.
Like how,
like what are the set of things that can
be done to make the future better?
Like you know,
like,
so I think the future where we are a
space fairing civilization and out there
among the stars.
This is very exciting.
This makes me look forward to a future.
This makes me want that future.
You know,
the things that need to be,
things that make you look forward to
waking up in the morning,
you wake up in the morning,
you look forward to the day before to
the future and a future where we are
spacefaring civilization and out there
among the stars.
I think that's very exciting.
That is a thing we want.
Whereas if,
if you knew we would not be a space
frank civilization,
but forever confined to Earth,
this would not be a good future.
That would be very sad.
I think
it would be the future of the,
the just the finite lifespan,
the earth itself and the solar system
itself that even though it's possibly,
you know what I mean?
How many,
how long do they feel like the sun and
the solar system is going to exist?
How many hundreds of millions of years.
Well,
it's probably,
if you're saying the windows,
the sun boil the ocean,
right?
For about 500 million years.
So is,
is it sad that we never leave because in
500 million years that happens?
Is that what you're saying?
No,
I just think like if there are two
futures and one futurists,
we're out there among the stars and the
things we read about and see in science
fiction movies,
the good ones are true and we have these
starships and we're,
we're,
we're going to see what other planets
are like and where a multitenant species
and the scope and scale of consciousness
is expanded across many civilizations.
And many planets and many star systems.
This is a great future.
This is a wonderful thing to me and
that's what we should strive for.
But that's biological travel.
That's cells traveling physically to
another location.
Yes.
Do you think that's definitely where
we're going?
No.
Yeah,
I don't think so either.
I used to think so and now I'm thinking
more likely less than ever.
Like almost every day.
Less likely.
We can definitely go to the moon and
Mars.
Yeah.
Everything will go to the asteroid belt
and we can go to the moons of Jupiter.
Saturn.
You can even get to Pluto.
That'd be the craziest place ever.
If we colonize Mars and retire,
formed it and turned it into like a big
Jamaica.
Just imagine they're going to be great.
It's.
There's amazing,
right?
We turned the whole thing into Cancun.
Well,
I mean over time it wouldn't be easy,
but yes.
If you could just want.
You could warm it up.
Yeah,
you can look it up.
You could add air.
You get some water there.
I mean over time,
hundreds of millions of years or
whatever it takes.
We're going to be a multiplanetary vcs.
That would be amazing species.
That's to be like air conditioning.
Sad.
I'm pro human.
Me Too.
Yeah,
me too.
I love humanity.
I think it's great.
We're glad as a robot that you love
humans because we love you too.
And we don't want you to kill us and eat
us.
And uh,
I mean strangely,
I think a lot of people don't like
humanity and see it as a blight,
but I do not.
But I think one of those,
I think part of that it's just they've
been,
you know,
they've been struggling.
When people struggle,
they associate their struggle with other
people.
They never internalize their problems.
They looked to other people is holding
them back and people suck and fuck
people and it's just,
you know,
it's a neverland.
Never ending cycle,
but not always.
Again,
most people are really good.
Most people,
the vast majority.
This may sound Corny,
it does sound Corny,
but love is the answer is the answer.
Yep.
Yeah,
it is.
It sounds quite because we're all
scared,
you know,
we're all scared of trying to love
people being rejected or someone take
advantage of you because you're trying
to be loving.
Sure.
But if we all could just relax and love
each other,
wouldn't hurt to have more love in the
world.
It definitely wouldn't hurt.
Yeah,
it'd be great.
we should do that.
Yeah.
I agreement really.
How do you fix that?
You have a love machine,
you know,
but to probably spend more time with
your friends and less time on social
media now deleting social media from
your applications,
from your phones and other that give you
a 10 percent boost to happiness was the
percentages.
I think probably something like that.
Yeah.
It's about a good 10 percent.
I mean,
the only thing I've kept as twitter
because I kind of like need some means
of getting a message out,
you know?
Right.
Um,
well that's about it.
So far so good.
Well,
what's interesting with you,
you,
he actually occasionally engage with
people on twitter.
Yeah.
It's what percentage of that is a good
idea?
Ha.
Good to question 10 percent.
It's mostly,
I think it's unbalanced.
More good than bad,
but there's definitely some bad.
So do you ever.
Hopefully the good outweighs the bad.
Do you ever think about how odd it is,
that weird feeling that you get when
someone says something Shitty to you on
twitter and you read it,
that weird feeling,
this weird little negative Joel.
It's like a subjective negative jolt of
energy they don't really need to absorb,
but you do anyway.
Like,
well fuck the score for Kim.
I mean there's a lot of negativity on
twitter.
It is,
but it's a weird.
It's in its form like the way if you
ingest it as if you're like you try to
be like a little scientist as you're
ingesting it,
you're like,
wow,
where does this?
And I'm even getting upset at some
strange person saying something mean to
me it's not even accurate.
I mean the vast number of negative
comments,
a syllabus for the vast majority who I
just ignore them.
The vast majority.
Yeah.
Every now and again,
get drawn in somewhat good.
It's not good.
Make mistakes.
Yes,
you could make mistakes.
We make some mistakes.
We're all human.
We can make mistakes.
Yeah,
it's hard and people love it.
When you say something and you'd take it
back and they're like,
fuck you.
We saved it forever.
Fucking screenshot that shit bitch.
You had that thought you had that
thought like,
well,
I deleted it.
Not good enough.
Who had the thought?
I'm better than you.
I never had that thought you had that
thought.
You piece of shit.
Look,
I saved it.
I put it on my blog.
Yeah,
sure why people think that that anyone
would think that deleting a tweet that
makes them go away.
It was like,
hello.
Then the Internet for awhile.
Yeah,
but it's even like anything is they
don't forever you to be able to delete
it because the problem is if you don't
delete it and you don't believe it
anymore,
it's really hard to say,
hey,
that thing above,
I don't really believe that anymore.
I changed the way I view things.
Yes,
because people go,
well,
fuck you already have that over there.
I'm going to just take that.
I'm not going to pay attention to that
shit.
You wrote her.
It's on your permanent record forever.
Tattoo on your permanent record.
Yeah.
It's like a tattoo.
You keep it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
it's,
it's this thing where there's,
it's
a,
there's a lack of compassion,
so lack of compassion issue.
People just like intentionally shitty to
each other all the time online and
trying to catch me.
It's more trying to catch people doing
something that's arrestable like a cop
trying to like get,
you know,
arrests on as his record.
It's like they're trying to catch you
with something more than.
They're logically looking at it thinking
it's a bad thing that you've done or the
idea they don't agree with so much.
They need to insult you.
Trying to catch you.
Yeah,
I mean it's way easier to be mean on
social media than it is to be mean in
person.
Yes.
Way Easier.
Yeah.
It's weird.
It's,
it's not a normal way of humans
interacting.
It's cheating.
You're not supposed to be able to
interact so easily,
but people were not looking at.
Yes.
You would never do that.
You'd never be so mean to somebody
looking in their eyes and if you did,
you'd feel like shit.
Most people.
Yeah.
Unless you're a sociopath,
you'd feel terrible.
Yes.
Elon Musk.
This has been a pleasure.
Yeah,
likewise.
Really has been.
It's been an honor.
Thank you for having me.
Thanks for doing this because,
uh,
I know you don't do a lot of a long form
stuff like this.
I hope I didn't weird you out and hope
you don't get mad that you smoke weed.
It's legal.
We're in California.
This is justice legal.
This whiskey we've been drinking.
Exactly.
This is all good.
Right?
Jaris.
Thank you.
Is there any message you would like to
put out other than love's the answer
because I think you really nailed it
with that.
No,
I think,
you know,
I think people should be nicer to each
other and give people and give,
give more credit to,
to others and don't assume that they're
mean until you know they're actually
mean,
you know,
just,
it's easy to demonize people,
usually wrong about it.
People a nicer than you think.
Get people more credit.
I couldn't agree more.
And,
uh,
I want to thank you not just for all the
crazy innovations you've come up with
and your constant flow of ideas,
but that you choose to spread that idea,
which is,
it's a,
it's a very vulnerable,
but it's very honest and I,
it resonated with me and I believe it.
I believe it's true too.
So thank you.
Oh,
you assholes out there.
Be Nice.
Be Nice,
bitch.
All right.
Thank you everybody.
Thanks.
All right,
ready?